What's up ladies and gentlemen?
One more time.
Here we go.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
squarespace.
Squarespace is one of our newest sponsors and a great website resource for
anyone who's thinking about starting a website and really has no idea how to
begin.
A squarespace's is truly the ultimate all in one platform.
You can create your own website yourself.
You don't need to learn html.
It's a setup,
very easy to use,
very intuitive design,
excellent images,
and you can.
You can set up a bunch of different variety is a websites and you can even try
it without paying for it.
If you go
sign up,
go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe.
No credit card needed.
Just try it out and start building your website.
If you decide to purchase,
then use the offer code Joe Three.
That's three because this is march that we're doing this podcast.
Use the code Joe and the number three and you get 10 percent off.
Your first purchase on new accounts includes monthly and annual plans.
That's squarespace.com.
Forward Slash Joe.
It's a really sweet setup,
including online commerce,
which is really a very convenient,
easy to use.
You can set up your own online store.
It's really fast,
really easy to do 24 slash seven support,
responsive design.
Your site's going to look great on any device,
iphone,
android,
whatever,
and you get a free domain name if you sign up for a year.
So you go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe,
and if you decide to sign up and use it,
use the code Joe Three and save yourself some Lula.
Ladies and gentlemen,
come on.
We're saving you 10 percent so you can design your luscious.
Delicious.
You're lovely suicide sitting on the train track.
Yeah.
What are they doing it?
We don't live forever.
We're crazy.
This is where we make love.
I want blah,
blah.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible].
I'm ting is a mobile cell phone company that uses a sprint backbone.
And uh,
I don't know how they did this.
I don't know if it was like other people have had this idea.
Are there people who have done things like this before,
but what they decided to do was,
I guess they rent,
they rent time on the sprint backbone and they sell it back to you.
And the way they do it is they have their company setup in a way that it makes
it.
Like if you were gonna like,
I wish my company did this,
I wish my company had no contracts.
I wish my company would refund money if I didn't use,
uh,
the,
the minutes credit on unused service if you use less than you thought you would,
tear drops you down and credits you the difference on your next bill.
So I've never heard of a company doing that.
It's beautiful.
I love hearing that Shit.
Unlimited devices on one plan.
You can have as many devices on you want on one plan and you can share pooled
minutes messages and megabytes.
And each device has a plan on a plant,
costs a flat fee of $6 per month.
It's like it's beautiful company.
Um,
they also have the best android phones.
You can buy really cool ones like the Samsung Galaxy note too,
which is that giant fucking delicious one kid's screen envy every time I see it.
So pretty bad ass looking foam.
They have the galaxy s three.
I think they're getting the s four.
That's how is that out yet?
The s four?
Not quite out yet.
It's not out.
It's on the way out.
They keep pumping these out,
man.
It's.
It's really interesting because they really have lit a fire under apple's ass
because for the longest time there was no benefit to having any device other
than an iphone.
I had that touch screen blackberry because I was trying to stick with verizon.
Oh my God.
What a piece of shit.
That was.
What a wretched clunky clicky piece of shit.
You're in Austin now.
You weren't in denial because you still might hate it.
I just liked verizon.
I used,
back then I used phones more.
I used my phone to make calls.
I was very,
very little texting and never online,
so for me it was just important that I could use it to,
you know,
to call people.
But then it was just too,
it was too hard.
He would try to get your email or something.
It was a fucking joke to try to write an email and that click,
click,
click.
Every time you touch it,
click,
click.
So Tonka Shits and you know,
you just see would look at the iphone,
you'd feel sad.
But that's not the case anymore.
These new phones are actually,
they have benefits over the iphone.
The biggest one being a screen screens are fucking huge.
The galaxy s three,
the one that I have,
it's beautiful.
And if you look at a website and it's such a different experience and looking on
a website on my phone and the note takes it to the next level of known as like
five inches.
It's fucking gigantic like me
snipped in on your lads.
If you go to Rogan.ting.com,
you save yourself 25 bucks on either a device or um,
or,
or credit for service as well.
So the 25 bucks is applicable to either one.
It's [inaudible] dot ting.com.
And again,
really great phones,
really great ethical company.
It just,
it all works,
bitches.
It's beautiful and delicious.
So go team for business.
I'm going with that is
probably something good.
They probably have better,
bigger plans or something.
Yeah.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t if you haven't seen the chimp kettlebells are out there,
uh,
the first of this new thing that we're doing called primal bells.
And what we've done is a hire artists to,
um,
create,
uh,
these,
these images to create sculptures of angry chimpanzees.
One of them we've got,
I don't want to give away,
I already gave away the gorilla,
the gorilla.
So dope.
I couldn't keep it together.
But there's,
there's a bunch of really cool ones we have coming out and it's all,
they're all designed by someone who does special effects models.
They do like,
you know,
monsters,
monster movie type Shit.
So we hired him to make a Kettlebell.
We also three d scanned it to make sure that it's totally,
completely balanced.
The problem with these sort of joke workout pieces of equipment is,
and then they look great,
but they're not as effective as the real thing.
These are as effective as any kettlebell you get.
You have to watch which way your hand it.
Um,
handle it so that the chimp face as a slam in your arm.
But even if it did,
it's okay.
I've,
I've used them both ways.
It's not that big of a deal,
especially if you're a manly man like myself,
but the point is that it's their excellently bounced.
We had unbalanced absolutely perfectly with really thick handles too.
So it's really difficult to use,
which is what you want.
You want something to really work your grip in.
If you've never had any kettlebell exercise in your life before,
I urge you to find a trainer and have someone show you in person.
If you can afford that,
if you can't,
there's a lot of online videos.
But,
um,
if you go to like youtube,
there's many,
many,
many online instructional that you can get for free.
But you want to really be diligent about your form.
You really want to be diligent about your actual fitness level.
Don't push yourself too quick and hurt yourself and you don't lift too much
weight too easily,
just in the beginnings or too quickly rather than beginning.
Try Light,
lighter weights.
Try just,
you know,
you're just trying to build slowly every day.
Just write it down.
Make yourself do it.
If you really want to get in shape and if you really want to work hard,
don't go all at once.
That's crazy because when you go all at once,
you break things.
You fuck up your muscles,
you pull things,
your hurt,
your knees.
Don't do that.
You gotta you gotta train if you're going to train hard and you should have been
training hard for years already,
and so the.
The idea behind a functional fitness like kettlebells or steel maces or steel
clubs,
these clubs,
bells,
all these different things that we sell is the idea of using things using
workout equipment that provides you with functional real world strength.
So if you're in the mountains and a mountain lion jumps and you managed to get a
hold of his neck,
how confident are you in your endurance?
How long can you fight this motherfucker off?
Is it a difference between life or death?
In some situations,
most likely the mountain lions can fuck you up unless you have some sort of a
knife or he's a pussy.
Could get lucky and find some pussy ass mountain lion that maybe got fucked up
by a bear a couple of weeks ago and it still doesn't have a stage legs back
under them.
PTSD,
PTSD.
Some woman got attacked by a wolf recently in Alberta.
Fucking crazy shit.
She had these bite marks on her neck,
but there was a bunch of people around.
So apparently the wolf flutter go big.
Two hundred pound Timberwolf just took this lady down and bit her neck and a
bunch of people around there and people were freaking out because there were so
many people and people were freaking out.
The wolf just bailed,
but he got so bold and so scary that he jumped on this chick and the chick just
got in her car and drove to the hospital.
It's a crazy story,
man.
Wolf let go of her neck.
I mean,
she's got these cuts,
like there's images of it.
You could find it online.
There's images of her neck.
She got off relatively lucky.
She's lucky it was on wolf a pack.
Well,
I think if it was a lone wolf,
it's also positive possible.
That's why it was so fucking hungry that got kicked out of the pack.
Like if it's a big old male,
you know,
it might be that it's on its way out and some new mail took over and now he's
fucked.
He's out there by himself.
That's how they die.
That's a.
that's a.
that's an exile on the wolf world.
That's a fucking terrible,
terrible thing.
Those,
I mean,
they're essentially saying,
we've got no room for any anymore,
dude.
You gotta you gotTa fucking kick the bricks.
As poor wolf's got to go out and try to get some elk himself.
It's hard for one both to kill an elk.
You got to get a gang of them and you've got no fucking box them in and take
them out by the legs and look for the little ones and you know,
but those wolves on their own man,
this bit,
this chick's neck.
Well maybe if the bitch Nigga little Jujitsu and had some kettlebell training,
she could fight off that Pussy Wolf that will obviously it was a pussy.
You know,
if they're like bites in the neck and then he's like,
fuck.
He got that close.
You're not going to try to eat her.
You know,
are we talking to dating now?
Are still with the wolves?
Okay Dude,
you can't say them on the podcast podcast.
We're talking about defending yourself.
Get Wolves
now by a wolf.
What if they were the best at it?
What if I get super dangerous?
You know,
every now and then someone got their pussy bit,
but for the most part,
like orgasms by Wolf,
eating your pussy.
He's like the greatest thing ever.
It's put their snout in there.
It's a really muscular tongues and that they're not scared to get dirty.
You know,
I don't know if this is appropriate,
but when I heard a lot of stories about women who are menstruating camping and
the blood attracted grizzly bears and you gotta be really careful camping with a
woman who's been destroyed.
God and what are the bare decides that you're a pussy for?
That's what they do and they find the one with that missing.
Oh my God,
that's so scary.
It's not a good image.
That's such a scary animal.
The scariest thing about them,
we've talked about this in the podcast before,
but is that they don't kill you.
They just started eating.
Some animals will kill you first.
Well,
that's a black bear.
No.
Even Grizzlies,
they don't kill you.
They will kill you eventually,
but they start eating you.
They don't.
They don't have that instinct like a panther does to bite your neck and stop
your life and then consume you and they don't do that because for two reasons.
One thing is probably because they're so fucking big and powerful.
It's like they don't really have any enemies like,
besides man,
right?
So they don't feel like once they got.
Yeah,
they just take the time and eat,
you know,
and they're so strong that like a deer can't really hurt them,
for bear gets a hold of a deer.
That deer.
Good,
good luck swatting at kicking and,
you know,
but uh,
a deer kicking can fuck up.
A mountain lion could kick him in the face,
break his jaw,
and then was the mountain lion.
Dude,
he's fucked.
He can't eat.
He's going to starve to death.
So the mountain lion,
it's imperative for to take that deer out as quickly and cleanly as possible.
They go white for the neck,
they roll onto the body.
I mean,
it's really like a Jujitsu move.
They choke the life out of you.
They always go for the neck.
They don't try to take you out like in the middle of your back,
you know,
they,
they go right where it's going to be the quickest,
most effective way.
Bears on do that.
They just started eating you.
They just hold you down and start eating.
Yeah.
Grizzly bears,
uh,
I mean,
I,
I was in Alaska two years.
I know a lot more than I should about bears probably,
but I think that the reason a lot of people survive grizzly bear attacks,
but not black bear attacks.
Two reasons.
One,
black bears climb trees.
Grizzlies don't.
So you can't climb a tree.
And the other thing is grizzlies will often,
and this ties into what you're saying,
grizzlies will often think they killed you and then they'll kick some dirt over
you so you can play dead with a grizzly.
They'll kick some dirt over you.
And often they'll come back later because they like the meat putrefying French
cheese.
They like,
it's stinky and gooey here.
They actually compost,
you know,
it really.
Do they cover you with leaves and dirt?
It's sort of a must be Dha.
Is it to hide or to accentuate the process?
I wonder.
Yeah.
Good cooking.
You are cooking.
You with brought dirty containing animals.
We know everybody is like that.
People love bears and I,
I think they're majestic and I'm certainly not saying we should eradicate them
for the face of the planet,
but the only reason why we love them is because they're not in our lives on a
daily basis.
If we had grizzly bears in our streets,
you would have fucking wheel problems,
man.
Like monster movie problems where it's going to eat your children right in front
of.
Have you seen grizzly man?
Have I seen his filling?
Huh?
Recommended to everyone.
Yeah.
I guess we were in the middle of a commercial.
Sorry.
No,
don't,
don't apologize.
That's how we like to do it.
I'm just a lot of good shit there folks.
If you go to a audit.com o n n I t,
there's all sorts of different supplements as well as cool fitness equipment,
but if you're looking for that kind of strength and functional fitness
equipment,
we have you covered battle ropes,
kettlebells,
club bells,
all that good shit.
Gummy bears,
but actually do have a company in Paris.
We have government.
We sell certain foods that we find finding me really healthy,
like a hemp protein powder and coconut oil and stuff along those lines.
But we also have these,
um,
Omega three gummy worms.
Wow.
Yeah.
My kids.
Well,
one of my kids likes it and the other kid is not into it at all.
We have these fish oil,
their official jellies.
One of my kids loves him.
She asked for all the time.
He fucking hates it.
The other one thinks it tastes like shit.
This is terrible.
Look at her face,
but the little one just gobbles it up.
It's really good for him.
You know,
it's a way of getting kids,
uh,
essential.
Uh,
central fatty acids.
A killer honey as well.
We got done Himalayan salt and all sorts of good shit.
O n n I t a,
the code named Rogan.
He will save 10 percent off any and all supplements.
I like the overview.
Just shows a bunch of boats in the water.
The what?
Review.
This is the overview for the.
It's a bunch of boats.
You guys sell boats.
It's like,
Hey,
we can get it from the city water.
What does it say?
Oh,
fish oil distributors.
Is that what it says?
No oil jellies for kids overview.
Here's a boat.
Yeah.
It doesn't say anything,
but we got our fish from a boat.
See boats float in the water.
That is really stupid.
Why would they show boats?
Did you know that?
Fish live in water and people don't live in water.
Look like shitty old birds.
Doesn't look like good water.
They come from like Norway.
They don't have.
They don't really need to have any better boats in that.
Just Shazam blue water,
you know?
Nice beach.
Well those are the boats that go and get our fish that we need to make our
essential jellies.
How dare you.
Brian,
do you ever watch that fucking deadliest catch show?
They don't have like the coolest boats.
Those guys aren't yachts.
We snuck this girl and using these boats.
Yeah.
What's that girl doing?
Certified young fellow kids.
Full of Shit.
They paid it all the hands like that.
She's like,
totally.
They give a real real chocolate if she can just fuck it.
We have a hershey's bar right behind the camera.
Honey,
I need to just make two fists like a fighter.
Chuck Liddell make leg.
Chuck Liddell.
Yeah,
they photoshop the.
The handcuffs offer thumbs up.
You can see like right here,
there's like a handcuffed that hasn't been photoshop off.
If you look at the left arm,
it looks clearly.
Duck taped doesn't look real at all.
What is the hair?
Okay.
Don't be a fucking doctor.
Laser.
Oh look,
she's got one strand of hair over white shoulder and the rest of her hair's
behind.
It's not a mystery at all.
You fuck.
No.
You're a conspiracy.
Tinfoil hat.
Picture Guy.
You're looking for issues.
This ain't even a real kid.
That's a boy's head.
They gave him fucking ponytails.
I got news for you.
Boys and girls look pretty much the same when therefore no one knows.
Really fucking branched out and run away from the pack yet,
but I'm on a Dotcom O,
n n I t go name,
Rogan.
Alright.
Dr Chris Ryan is here.
We're going to figure some shit out folks.
We're gonna.
Explore some ideas.
We're going to expose some cultural problems.
We have hit the music.
No,
please.
Okay,
the Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast all day,
international man of mystery World Travel,
man,
author,
Xtrordinair.
You're a,
you have a broad range of experiences that you can draw upon Mr Chris Ryan,
and to appreciate you very much coming back here again.
Thanks man.
It's an honor.
Oh please.
It's an honor to have you back to your book is amazing.
If you haven't read it.
I've been reading it over the past few months.
Um,
along with the new Steve Rinella book meat eater.
I can throw you back and forth with this book.
It's a great book,
man.
There's so much interesting shit in it.
It's a,
it's such a fascinating sort of exposure about sexuality and evolution and how
we sort of evolved and how we've,
you know,
got to this point where it's kind of gotten away from us and there's all this.
I think Duncan trussell said it best.
He said that you exercise shame from people.
You know what that term,
until I told you I'm working on a new website using squarespace,
which is not bullshit.
I'm not saying that,
but my,
you know,
we've got Chris Ryan and then under it says a author,
public speaker or something.
I love that phrase.
Yeah,
you're.
That book is.
Yeah.
For a lot of people it makes you go,
oh,
okay.
That's why these fucked up thoughts or come,
I'm not fucked up.
Everybody's system's fucked up.
Oh,
we're living in this crazy time of shame,
chime of a
oddly defined identities and roles that we're supposed to take on.
That seemed very unnatural.
You know,
and it's,
it's weird times.
We live in weird time sexually.
I think we do,
you know,
the Chinese thing,
may you live in interesting times,
which is a curse,
you know,
but I think we do.
We do live in very interesting times.
There's a quote we use in the book from the playwright,
Arthur Miller,
who was married to Marilyn Monroe for awhile.
He said,
uh,
an era can be considered over when it's basic.
Illusions have been exhausted.
I'd love that quote.
It's basic illusions who have been experienced and I think we live in a time
where pretty much all our basic illusions are exhausted politics.
Nobody thinks they're the shit that's going on in Washington is anything other
than,
you know,
back the yield trading for whatever,
I'm banking,
nobody believes banking is for the good of the country anymore.
It's like people have realized that everyone's on the take.
The institutions are not respected and that includes marriage to a large extent.
And so there's this struggle going on over marriage and monogamy and gay rights,
you know,
in terms of a same sex marriage.
So I think we're in this war.
I mean there's so many things,
diet,
you know,
you're on the forefront of a lot of this sort of recalibrating,
what works,
what's right,
what actually has benefits,
you know,
as opposed to the bullshit that we're being fed all the time.
So.
And I think a lot of that's due to the Internet probably,
that you can,
you know,
if your message is strong enough,
it doesn't matter who you are,
who's backing you,
you can reach people.
So I think,
yeah,
I think we're in really interesting times.
It's an effect on our culture of that the workforce,
the workplace brings and it's,
excuse me
everyday during the,
at the workplace,
you know,
some of my black,
but uh,
no,
I'm good.
Thanks man.
That's a beard.
That's a beer at least 10 minutes.
Black Butte,
but tea butte.
It's a delicious Porter Ale.
I would like to have one of those and get moved.
It's um,
yeah,
I,
I drank some of that for the first time when I was a man.
I want to say Chicago where I think it was in Chicago.
Yeah.
It was like the greatest beer I've ever had in my life from bend,
Oregon.
Yeah.
What's the name of the company?
Uh,
the shoots,
shoots brewery.
Hey,
how dare you.
They should be a sponsor.
How about we just pump them up for free?
For free.
All right,
well that's good.
It's good beer.
And that's from a guy who doesn't like porter much.
I was saying earlier,
it's normally kind of heavy and sweet for me,
but this is nice.
Yeah,
no,
that's delicious.
What are we talking about before we got off workplace?
You're talking about workplace.
Thanks for the.
I really feel like because of the fact that you have to,
when you're in an office all day,
especially,
um,
with men and women working together,
there's this sort of professionalism that you have to project.
There's this sort of fake way of communicating where you,
you've completely eradicated anything sexual from the menu of conversation and
even discussing it in the periphery,
dancing around it with a joke can easily get you fired or you know,
about this dongle gate thing.
Are you aware of this memo?
I've heard reference to it,
but I haven't looked into it.
It's a fascinating story that has taken place over the last few days in the tech
world.
There was a woman,
a self professed feminist blogger.
Woman's.
Sorry folks.
I've got a little phlegm,
Jimmy,
me,
um,
some tissues I gotta blow my nose.
I'm.
This woman was at a conference and some men behind her made a joke about
dongles.
It was someone said Dongguan says this essentially is that dongle part of
something.
But it was what they're essentially doing was I'm doing like a high tech version
of Beavis and butthead.
He said,
dongle biggest dawn was,
you know,
so these guys,
I don't know what the joke was,
but.
So she takes a photo of these guys and then puts that photo online and says,
Hey,
these guys are violating the code of conduct for the seminar and these guys are
on a,
you know,
in your conference there,
they're making jokes about dongles are not cool.
Okay.
So these guys get fired and one guy gets fired.
He's got three kids and this woman writes his blog,
sort of justifying like the environment that,
you know,
that sort of makes cool.
And that's the reason why she decided to come out was because there was a little
girl on stage or a little girl in the room or whatever.
And she was thinking,
what was this little girl?
If I don't stand up and stop this,
what is she going to be exposed to it?
Which is of grandiose when you're talking
about Dongles,
Jesus fucking Christ.
But what's truly fascinating about this whole thing is a,
first of all,
the response by the Internet because the man was fired.
Um,
but don't put those guys online.
Dude,
why are we doing that?
I mean there's no need to keep.
Yeah,
I know.
I mean,
I just don't think they,
they didn't ask to be online.
Those guys never asked to be on those.
Those photos were taken by this woman and it turned into this big thing.
She has like an online media thing that she does already.
So she is like a big presence,
a lot of twitter followers.
And she just took a photo of these guys and just put them out in the world for
no reason.
I mean they didn't ask for it and she says,
here's the guys that tell the Dongle joke.
So one guy gets fired.
She writes this crazy blog and anonymous jumps in there,
like,
what?
Fuck you.
Oh really?
They were like,
this is absolutely fucking posture is the way this woman's behaving is
repulsive.
And it just went off.
And so they threatened the company and they said they were going to go after
their clients and they were gonna,
you know,
denial of service attacks and whatever they were going to do.
Like,
I don't know if you need even directly threatened it or indirectly threaten it,
but they're like,
you,
you got to,
this is just the beginning.
You've got to get rid of this check.
And they fired her immediately.
Oh,
I thought you meant the company that fired the guy.
Did they different kinds of.
I don't know if they brought the guy back,
but you really,
the guy should get a job at a company that's not a bunch of fucking pussies
because that's the most ridiculous shit ever.
And one man,
isn't it?
Like it's nothing.
You know,
I,
I haven't had a job since the eighties,
so I'm not the guy that really,
you know,
but I can't imagine pissing into a cup to have a job.
I don't understand that drug test,
drug test for insanity and complete insanity.
The fuck does it matter if I smoked a joint two weeks ago and I come into work
today,
what the hell are we talking about?
It's insane.
Complete total insanity and it's just this sort of
designed to get people moving in this direction of blind obedience and that's
what your employer would like for you.
But by the way,
I think that's another one of these basic illusions that's exhausted.
We got ran Paul coming out for legalizing drugs.
Yes.
I just saw the headline.
You know,
so I,
I think maybe we've turned a corner.
It's gotten so crazy that,
you know,
anonymous is standing up.
That's great.
I think the Internet represents the real mind of the people today and I think
when,
when a big movement like this sweeps across the Internet,
and this is a very minor one,
let's go with a major one.
Let's go with wikileaks.
The overwhelming support of Wiki leaks by people online as opposed to how it's
represented in the mainstream media is a big difference,
isn't it?
People Online,
it's like people 35 and under.
Mostly.
I don't think so anymore.
No,
I don't think that's applicable anymore.
I think pretty much everybody's online.
I think there's been over the last decade there's been this assimilation towards
older and older folks and then the people who are 30 or now 40 and that's just,
it's,
you know,
I think the ideas are too powerful and the method of distribution is too
powerful and now we're dealing with this ancient paradigm that doesn't,
it doesn't really work with the amount of information that we have today.
It's like this old car that we're trying to keep fixing and putting new tires on
your fucking model t it's a piece of shit it worse.
Cuba as Cuba's got least cool cars,
they really take care of.
Well,
it's an amazing model of like recycling and true recycling and the unnecessary
aspects of constantly getting new and improved things.
A friend of mine wrote a book called the Chase Chevrolet and Castro's oldsmobile
or something like that.
I mean,
his name is Richard Schweid.
It's,
he's written this guy so interesting.
He's published seven books,
one on Chili peppers,
one on cockroaches,
one on,
uh,
you know,
life after death.
One on Cuban cars,
he just like w eels,
he's got a book on,
he just like gets a hair up his ass and decide something's interesting and he'll
just run it down and write a book about it and then move onto something else.
That's amazing.
Uh,
what,
what I was saying earlier before I got,
before I got sidetracked about the workplace is that the suppression of your
true humanity in the workplace,
your,
your ability to be free and to be yourself and to be,
to joke around and have fun,
especially when there's intersects politics when there's,
you know,
there's a cross of men and women working together.
There's this sort of like fakeness that goes on all day and then there's this
other level of fakeness that goes on when you're out in the night lifetime
you're trying to get laid like,
so there's that fakeness as well.
And there's just such a small percentage of time that humans,
men and women throughout the day interact with each other on a truly honest
level,
you know?
So like it takes fucking decades to understand each other.
It takes decades as a man under just try to wrap your head around the idea of
wanting babies growing inside of you and wanting dicks and you know,
and being attracted to men.
Just wrapping your head around that.
It's a very strange concept because we bullshit each other all day at work
before because we bullshit each other when we'd go out on dates.
So social events,
we pretend to be someone you know,
more sophisticated or interesting than we truly are.
Um,
I think that the amount,
the amount of time it takes before you start understanding how people really are
as opposed to these bizarre patterns that we keep following,
you know,
it seems,
and you didn't even mention media.
All the bullshit media pumps into us about each other.
Men and women have a unique relationship with,
uh,
with television.
And then had been
on a couple shows that went on a long time.
I was on news radio for five years and then it was on fear factor for six years
or so when people say,
oh,
there's a conspiracy and the government's trying to dumb us down through
television.
That's not what's happening.
What's happening is that's what you're buying,
that's what they're selling because that's what you're buying and that's one of
the reasons why it's gotten darker and weirder over the past few years.
Just because you're on the Internet now and the walking dead could not have
fucking existed a decade ago.
No way you could have that on television.
I saw a dude get his leg hacked off with a hatchet,
you know?
I mean,
you see shit.
I couldn't believe what was the sheer violence and insanity of the walking dead
is impossible without the internet and video games.
Video Games,
absolutely these uncensored environments,
but that information's there now,
so they have to adjust and change things,
but the reason why fear factor existed or or CSI exists,
it's not that the government is like trying to convince you.
If you make a mistake,
we'll catch you.
We can take your fingerprints from the air,
you know,
like,
no,
no.
It's just,
that's what you want.
You want crime shows.
You're buying crime shows.
If you buy crime shows because you're scared because you look what's happening
in the world will hold what if the bad guy,
so you're living your life in these weird paranoid ideas through this artificial
medium,
but no one's trying to brainwash you.
You think they are,
but it's really more a matter of this is what people actually bought and is it
because that's what they've been sold forever.
Yeah,
that too.
Definitely that too,
but there's a lot of dummies out there.
There's a lot of domains that just want to sit in front of the TV and watch
someone get go to what's going to happen on law and order.
I'm going to guess the bad guy's going to lose because I'm.
No,
I agree.
I agree with you.
Although I do think that there is.
It's not brainwashing,
but I think who was at Marshall Mcluhan said the medium is the message,
right?
Yeah.
So there's certain things that you sell that are,
that are easier to sell through TV.
So you sell those.
Right,
and they're the structure.
I mean,
I'm reading this book now,
civilized to death.
It's called him,
so I'm really like deep into the shit,
but it's like there are institutions are organic beings,
companies are organic beings,
so they,
you're right,
they sell the,
they provide what sells because they're,
they need to eat,
they need to feed,
you know,
and grow.
But I do think that there are structural,
how can I say it,
like structural biases that,
that divert or,
or,
uh,
you know,
sort of focus the media in different ways and I think Internet is great because
it's so dispersed.
Whereas TV is very,
I'm selling to you.
I don't hear a thing you say,
except through Nielsen ratings or some shit like that.
It's like they're getting smoke signals.
They're not getting a conversation.
Whereas the Internet,
it's like,
wow,
you've got clicks.
You eyes,
you can
measure everything.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
The idea of,
you know,
this is what we're going to offer you.
It doesn't exist on the internet and the choices are so vast that and the
freedom that anybody like you have a podcast,
right?
Generally speaking,
as you can tell,
it's my style.
What's your preference for this podcast?
Um,
that,
the,
you know,
any,
anything along these lines that the youtube videos that people have the young
Turks or have these video.
My last episode was with the Young Turks that couldn't have existed.
We talked about.
Yeah,
are they like you,
it couldn't have existed without,
without the Youtube possibility,
the Internet possibility without,
with,
without that sort of a platform.
And I think that sort of overwhelming the old paradigm and it's slowly starting
to a road.
Um,
but I,
I also feel that the workplace,
like people,
people having to bullshit all day is counterproductive to it.
And it becomes a major part of your awake time program.
Yeah.
It's so American.
I have to say in Spain,
you know,
I can't speak for Spain in general,
but I've been there 20 years.
So I,
I,
you know,
I've,
I'm pretty well familiar with the culture,
but it's one of the things I love about Spain is that politically correct sort
of,
you know,
men are the enemies of women and adolescent joking can get you fired from your
job.
That isn't happening now.
Women could have a legitimate point by saying,
yeah,
because women's status in Spain isn't as high as it is in there aren't legal
protections and that,
you know,
women get harassed in the street or whatever,
and that's all true.
So I don't mean to say Spain is across the board better,
but one thing I noticed in Spain and I love about Spain,
is that women,
women don't assume you're a rapist because you smile at them,
you know,
they,
they don't assume you've got bad intentions.
In fact,
they assume you probably have good intentions and you just find them attractive
and they smile back and everybody keeps walking and there's no.
It's like a win win.
You know,
there's no assumption of victimization going on.
I think in America there's this assumption,
you know,
that,
that you know why there's a little girl on stage and these guys are making a
dumb ass jokes somehow that's connected and I got to expose this.
I don't,
I don't see that in Spain you don't see that sort of shit.
Well,
the,
the fury that people had was this.
They weren't joking with her.
They weren't,
they were joking amongst themselves and literally the most innocent language
possible for describing a dick or alluding to a dick and that was enough for her
to go.
I've had enough like the.
There's a craziness to that and someone made a video called toxic women and
stupid men and it's on youtube and deep,
very in a very intelligent way.
Details why people that think like this or a real issue and men who allow
them to get away with it without saying this is preposterous.
Their real issue too,
because there's a lot of white nights out there.
There's a lot of really dumb weak dudes that want to pretend that there with the
girls,
they think like,
you know,
you're right.
These men are assholes and they'll make videos about it and what they're looking
for is like feminine Brownie points.
They want feminist to look at them and say,
yeah,
you're one of us,
and it's not necessarily that they don't actually think that way.
A lot of people are like,
you're wrong,
but I,
I believe you do think like that,
but I'm telling you that the motivation for anybody thinking like that is false.
You have a crazy,
ridiculous way of looking at things.
It's unbalanced.
If you had no sex whatsoever,
not male nor female,
and you look at that as two human beings and one human being was fired because
another human being made a joke about something that was being referenced
onstage in a playful manner.
Should that person be taking sex out of it?
Should that person be fired?
Right?
And if you say yes,
you're a cunt,
that's,
that's the reality of the situation.
You're a toxic person.
That's a shitty way of looking at things.
And by the way,
I should stress that this woman did not want these guys to be fired and she did
not think that was her intent.
She wanted them shut up.
Whatever is maybe she's self righteous.
Maybe she likes to go off on tangents.
I don't think she should be fired.
I don't think he should be fired.
I think it has nothing to do with whatever the fuck they do during the day,
but I think it's fascinating when people are forced to be behaving in a certain
way.
Like you're,
you're,
you're locked into this sort of nonsense environment where you can't even talk
about dongles.
Yeah.
You know,
there's an article on salon.com,
I think last week I linked to it and it started this big firestorm on my
facebook page where a woman wrote about an experience she'd had the first time
she'd had sex.
I think she was 15 or something and she was with a guy a couple of years older.
And,
um,
she just said she had a few drinks.
You read it.
Yeah.
And so she was saying that wasn't rape.
I made a bad decision.
I had sex that I later regretted it wasn't rape.
And apparently like,
oh,
there's a huge firestorm around this.
Yes,
there is.
Because there's the feminist movement right now.
Then one of the ideas that they're pushing is the idea that is in place,
I believe in Sweden.
Whereas the,
you know,
where the,
the idea being that regret,
um,
means that you can withdraw your consent,
which is where a Julian Assan is being accused of rape the woman he is
supposedly rape,
went out with them again the next night
and had sex with them right before what he was being accused of.
I don't want to speak out of school,
but I'm pretty sure it was called surprise sex.
It was the idea they were sleeping and they had sex again without a condom.
Yeah,
exactly.
And she didn't want this or she was upset at this or whatever,
you know,
obviously they were looking to get at him for something else,
but that's about as obvious.
You can get that one.
I mean that is just fucking,
it's just so happens that it's the same guy that had no beef with them about
leaking all the information.
That's cool because there's no law against that.
Right?
Is that what's going on?
But the other shit you can,
you can lock them up in a fucking.
Didn't Brenda this morning?
Yeah.
Fuck man.
They torture Bradley Manning truly torchy's a hero that was in solitary
confinement for some insane hundreds and hundreds of days with no contact with
another person,
which they say literally can make you crazy.
Yeah,
sure.
And they wouldn't,
they would take his clothes off because they thought that he was a security
risk.
So he's cold and naked lights all night lights constantly,
and you know,
for what,
because he did what really his patriotic duty led him to believe that he should
do.
You should release information that he believes is contrary to the nature of the
contrary to the idea of what most people view of the military as,
as only good guys over there killing bad guys.
And contrary to the law.
Yes.
You know,
international and American law.
Yeah.
He,
what he did was what the New York Times is supposed to do.
You know what Daniel Ellsberg.
Yeah.
There's a,
you know,
so I think the,
I,
the view of that,
that's getting back to the Internet thing on the Internet,
that's pretty.
I mean,
most of the people that I communicate with that's pretty much unanimous.
pretty much everybody is like,
well,
you know,
at the very least this exposes a real issue that should be dealt with in the
military,
but you don't hear that from mainstream media for mainstream media.
They have eliminated that guy from the discussion.
You never hear him being talked about.
See,
that's what I was saying earlier,
like the structure of the of the institution dictates what information can go
through there.
So because of the corporate interest,
because Ge owns NBC or whatever their and also makes the fucking missiles and
the helicopters and the rest of it,
they're not going to be able to take that perspective because they're not
independent.
That's bullshit,
right?
Well,
as some people like the young Turks come along,
they really become archaic.
They don't make any sense anymore because the young Turks will tell you,
you know,
they're going to tell you what they believe.
One hundred percent with that guy believes what?
They might not be.
Right.
They may be mean.
He was off about Breitbart,
about what the whole Andrew Wiener thing he made fun of Breitbart for releasing
that Jank.
Yeah.
Saying he's an idiot for doing it and it turned out to be true,
but you know that,
that he,
that's him.
That's him.
You know what I mean?
He's talking straight to the camera,
so maybe it doesn't have the correct information at the time,
but what he's telling you,
it's not being pushed by producers.
It's not being pushed by a network not being pushed by a corporate entity behind
the network.
Right?
You can't say that about the news that we've come to accept as the mainstream
news,
whether it's CNN or Fox.
There's no individual voice is no individual point of view and you know,
especially being.
Occasionally you'll have people give editorials,
but those editorials or just Jesus Christ,
Allah,
cartoonish.
They're cartoonish and nonsensical.
Especially like Fox News is going to be about the Democrats and Obama is fucking
up and we turn to socialism.
It's going to be so hot.
It's so obvious.
You don't even have to say it.
Just show me what color flag you hold them up.
You've got a red flag or a blue flag.
I your message.
Just show me a red,
a flash of red.
And that idea is basically just as good as whatever the fuck comes out of your
mouth.
Yeah.
You're going to have to have me back a third time because we're never going to.
Oh,
we will though,
man.
We will.
But I really wanted to have you one after this.
This thing,
this dongle gate broke out because
I think one of the things that your book really,
really highlights is the weirdness in which women are not supposed to except
their sexuality or accept the fact that they get horny or broadcasted in any way
or even you know,
it acknowledge it and that if there's a sexual joke going on where a man,
even if he doesn't even involve that woman,
make some sort of a sexual joke,
that somehow that woman is a victim because she doesn't want to have anything to
do with sex.
Right?
She doesn't want to have anything to do with their,
either their advances or jokes about it.
Korean image.
You know,
the Victorian era.
You only had sex with your wife in order to have babies.
You had sex to have sex with.
Court assigns with prostitutes,
with,
you know,
the housemaid with whatever you didn't fuck your wife for fun or for pleasure.
Was that across the board.
Kevin agreed.
Upperclass Victorian British society across the board,
you know,
not on,
in France and other European societies.
There is a different vibe,
but that's the society Darwin came out.
Right.
And as we tried to explain in the book,
that's the mentality that informs our understanding and the scientific view of
human sexual revolution because Darwin was an uptight guy.
He was great.
He was a genius.
He's a cool guy,
but he was super repressed.
Sexual.
He never had sex ever.
Right.
Isn't the only with his wife whom,
who was his first cousin from the Wedgewood family,
which are the Wedgewood,
China.
Fortunately they still,
they're still making China and in England.
Um,
and she was 30,
I think he was 29.
And his brother married with Newton.
Newton was a sexual right.
Yeah.
Didn't have during the.
Excuse me.
During the Victorian era,
didn't they cover up like legs of pianos?
Right.
And tables and chairs.
Oh yeah.
Because it would excite people.
It's so amazing.
It's like,
it's like
the Burka,
now you know why?
Oh,
it's crazier than the Burka,
but you know,
what's cool about the burqa and I'm doing this,
I'm pitching this TV show,
which seems like it's going to get picked up by the way.
And,
and the,
um,
one of the episodes is about,
is based on the story I heard from a woman who worked at Victoria's secret in
London and she told me that most of the lingerie they sold was to very wealthy
Saudi and Kuwaiti women who came in and we'd just buy out the store because they
were sexy lingerie under their Berkus.
Yeah.
But it's under that stupid 10.
They do.
I mean,
it's got to be compensating for the fact that they're forced to wear that stupid
outfit.
I don't think there's anything good about that outfit.
I mean,
the only thing good about it is if you're the man like,
man,
nobody gives a look at this says mine's going into the tent.
It's just the what,
you know,
what's offensive.
Not the religious connection to it,
but the suppression,
the idea that a woman has to wear that.
Right.
It's the most depressing thing ever.
You're covering everything about your identity,
right?
Especially it fucks up a girl if she's in a shit relationship and she's looking
for another dude.
She's looking for a little escape plan.
You know that guy has no.
What the fuck is getting into dress getting abused and nobody can see her.
Her bruise marks.
That's another way that.
Yeah.
That's another point.
Anyway,
I jumped off.
What were we talking about?
That
shit before.
Oh Man,
I'm not even stone.
Yeah.
Oh,
we were just talking about the suppression of sexuality that women don't feel
like a
Koreans in Darwin and all that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
when we originally pitched this book,
it was called what Darwin didn't know about sex and the idea was to write a
biography of Darwin sex life and then tie that into our modern misconceptions of
sexuality because he went and he had lots of opportunity,
right?
He went on the Beagle all down around South America,
across the South Pacific.
They stopped in Tahiti,
which is sexual paradise,
especially in the 19th century.
It was,
it was sexual paradise.
That's why the mutiny on the bounty happened because the,
the bounty.
You've seen the movie,
right?
The Marlin Brando.
I never saw that movie.
Well,
it's this,
uh,
so the,
the,
the bounty I guess was captain,
I don't remember what his name was,
captain something flusher or something like that.
But anyway,
it was a British,
a whaling ship I think,
or mapping ship maybe.
But anyway,
it stopped in Tahiti to spend about a month or two months there to like,
you know,
get fresh water and fix the ship and do all this stuff.
Meanwhile the dudes went down and they were on the island and there's a very
relaxed sexual situation into hedy and in many parts of the world.
And so these repressed British sailors who hadn't seen a woman and God knows how
long.
Suddenly there are all these beautiful women around who were happy to have sex
with them just for fun.
And uh,
so these guys are getting laid left and right.
And then the,
the bad ass captain says,
all right,
everybody back on the ship,
we're going back to see.
They get about four hours out to sea.
And there's a mutiny because the dudes are like,
fuck this,
we're going to go back to England.
We're going back to the hedy men.
So that's what they did.
So this is this famous case because there was like lots of Nice Pussy.
You mean Nice women on your say pussy,
you're,
you're objectifying women.
You're breaking them down to one body part.
I know what year,
Hey,
that's even worse.
I,
your intentions are pure.
But for our women friends out there,
that would be the white knight take on it.
Well done.
Calling them,
calling them by their sexual organs.
It's really not cool,
man.
Well last night I was at a party and a woman said something,
said some guy was a real dick.
And I and everyone laughed.
I said,
that's funny.
If someone was a country I'd would be sort of nasty.
Right?
So we got into this whole conversation about how come one body parts offensive
and the other isn't well is like if she called him a coc,
that guy's a cock.
That still,
depending on how the guy felt about the girl,
you know,
if he thought she thought he was the shit,
that would be a problem,
that'd be devastating.
I was a couple of weeks ago I gave a Ted talk or talking about this corporate
environment and um,
you know,
ted is Ted's wonderful.
I think you had a guest.
You're the guy who was there.
Anyone.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Graham Hancock,
who also has had issues.
Graham Hancock's had a very interesting situation and shelter.
Rupert sheldrake is good friends with Stanley Kripner.
You're going to be interviewing Saturday.
Yeah.
He probably knows hancock as well,
I don't know.
But all those old hippie stick together.
Yeah.
Intellectual,
freaky guys.
Um,
but uh,
anyway,
so I've got this presentation and when I did the rehearsal,
one of the slides and the presentation that I've used all over and know colleges
all over and stuff,
it's got.
I'm talking about testicular ratio and how that explained certain things about
our ancestors.
So I've got in one corner,
there's a gorilla lying on his back and the sun and there's like nothing.
He's got no balls at all.
They're like the size of kidney beans.
They're inside his abdomen,
so you don't see anything.
On the other corner,
there's a Banaba who's got balls the size of chicken eggs,
and in the middle there's a picture of this buddy of mine in a,
in a speedo sitting on a hammock and he's got pretty big balls and so the law,
it says like gorilla,
but Nobo and over my friend it says Italian.
Right.
That always gets a huge laugh when I do that.
I did this at Ted and they were like,
okay,
you know,
after the rehearsal they're like,
oh,
that was really good.
That's great.
Except that one.
And they.
They thought Italians would be offended.
Oh my God.
I'm always saying,
you tell that Italian,
he's got big balls.
That's a compliment.
Little do they know they have big balls because the Italian women are so
permissible.
Read the book.
Yes.
Devastating.
Devastating to the Italian mentality.
I can't believe it.
Maybe that's the part that's insulting.
The size of your package is directly proportionate to how slutty girls around
you are.
I shouldn't say slutty and that was a another fascinating aspect of your book
that I learned the origins of the word promiscuous,
that everybody was sort of assumes that promiscuity,
when United State Girls Promiscuous,
that she just sleeps with strangers and runs around.
She's got loose morals.
That's not the root of the word.
The root of the word is mixed,
meaning she has sex with more than one person.
She has relations with more than one person.
Generally speaking,
probably knew those people her entire life because the real origins of these
sort of orgiastic tribal societies of that,
there's only 50 of them.
They were living together in the woods and they knew each other from the time
they were born and they had sex with each other and they had sexual
relationships with more than one person.
And our ideas of,
you know,
monogamy,
it's great if it works for you.
If it works for you in 2013 and the corporate world and the legal world is
great,
but if you look at 50 people living alone in the woods,
staying bonded together,
the best way for everybody to truly love each other as everybody fucks
everybody.
I mean you,
you really are like monkey people.
I mean your,
your monkey people with more advanced genetics and more advanced tools and shit,
but you're essentially living not much different than you know,
than an animal with tools.
You know,
I mean,
that's how people at the dawn of time lived.
Those people,
it would benefit them to be sexually engaged.
Each.
It would benefit them to be polyamorous.
It would benefit them to have love spread out,
you know,
deep,
intense love with bunch of tribal members.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no,
no question.
In fact,
when I was,
you know,
I,
I'd done all this research on tribal people and they're really interesting
rituals that are seem designed to make sure that people don't break down into
nuclear families,
right?
They,
they're designed to make sure even though you and this woman really like being
together and,
and you know your hammocks are next to each other and you spend most of your
time together.
That's great.
And we're not saying that there was no pair bonding right in prehistory,
but all these cultures seem to have these rituals to make sure that you and your
woman both have sex with other people,
right?
So like they're tattooing ceremonies where everybody has sex and it's prohibited
to have sex with your normal partner.
Whoa.
Or there what Wacky fucking cultures.
If it's in the Amazon,
there are lots of the men in the South Pacific.
That's what happens when you don't have the Internet.
Start getting crazy
sets one assholes idea email.
It's one guy,
Richard,
I'm going to fuck your wife.
You're going to fuck my wife.
I want to fuck your wife.
Dude,
let me make it a law.
A law firm.
You have to make it a law that's fucking silly that,
I mean they're social engineering is no better than ours or theirs.
They'll do what you want to do.
This other societies,
the
Kulina,
uh,
Paula Don pollock was the anthropologist who lived with them for 20 years.
He talks about this ritual,
I don't know how to pronounce it,
but uh,
the,
the translates to the order to get meat and the women will wake up in the and
they,
they get together and they say,
okay,
let's do this thing today.
So they all start singing and they'll go around the village singing the song
that translates to you guys are lazy.
We don't get enough meat,
when are you going to give us some meat?
We want me,
right?
So they're singing this and it's.
And I asked him,
does meet to have a double meaning it?
And he said,
yeah,
definitely.
It's like same as go hunting but also give us some Dick,
right?
So while they're singing the song,
they go around and the women will beat on the post that's holding the guys
hammock.
And that means if you go hunting today and you bring back some meat,
I'll sleep with you tonight.
So it's like a motivation to get out of your hammock and go hunting,
but you can't hit the post of your normal partner.
It has to be someone else.
Right?
So then the men can,
if they don't,
like,
if you don't want to have sex with a woman who hit your post,
you can say,
oh my stomach today,
you know,
whenever I'm not feeling well you don't have to do it.
But.
So the guys who get up,
they'll like get up and be all,
oh,
you know,
grumbly and pissed off and then they'll go leave the village together.
But this area they hunt mostly monkeys.
And so they hunt independently,
right?
Because the monkeys are spread out.
So.
But before they split up to go hunting,
they'll agree to meet at this certain point before they go into the village.
So the uh,
or the camp or whatever.
So they'll go out,
some of them will get a monkey,
someone they meet back at this place and they cut up the monkey so that
everybody has a piece of meat going back into the village.
So everybody gets laid,
right?
So it's like pretty clearly,
this is all about mixing it up and it's not just for fun because there's nothing
else to do.
It's also to,
to,
um,
to mitigate the risk of conflict,
right?
Because if you get possessive about other people and their sexuality,
you're going to have lots of conflicts and conflict among this small shows.
Social Group,
as you say,
it's 50 to 150 maximum,
right?
Because of Dunbar's number,
which we can get into if you want.
But we can be pretty sure that the groups were never more than 150 individuals.
So the worst thing that can happen is you get schisms within that group because
you're all depending on each other.
You know,
some people are better hunters than others.
Some people are better at cooking or making bows and arrows,
sheds and all this kind of stuff.
Is that the origin of Dunbar's number?
Is that why we only have room in our head for supposedly 150 close
relationships?
Yeah.
Dunbar's is a biologist that either Cambridge or Oxford,
I don't remember which,
but he was looking at um,
uh,
the,
the brain size of different primates and he found that he could predict the
social,
the group of the social,
uh,
size of the social group of any primate by looking at its neocortex.
And so when he looked at humans and made that calculation,
he said,
okay,
it should be about 150.
And then they looked at the anthropological record and they found,
yeah,
interesting.
When these social groups grew to more than 150,
they split.
They tend to split into other groups,
not
acrimoniously just because
this.
So we've sort of developed a,
a need for a certain amount of space.
It's,
yeah,
it's like that's as many people as we can keep track of.
And because we didn't encounter large groups that was adequate for the time and
it takes a long fucking time for the human genetics to adjust to their new
environment,
which is very odd.
But it made sense for a million years,
for a million years.
It totally made sense until the last few hundred and then things just have
gotten so strange that the human genetics are essentially the same as those
people that are living in the Amazon.
Yeah,
I mean,
there have been some changes.
There's a great book called the 10,000 year explosion that talks about the,
the genetic changes that have happened since agriculture.
What are they like the most significant ones?
Well,
eye color,
skin color,
hair color,
you know,
there,
there were no blue eyed people 10,000 years ago.
They know that DNA.
Wow.
They've got like 10,000 year old people.
DNA.
Like that old dude that fell on the,
uh,
the ice man selling the a glacier.
That's,
if you haven't heard of that story,
believably amazing story because it's such a rare fine.
This guy died and he fell in a crevasse and the glacier went over him and didn't
wipe them out.
And that's really rare.
Most things,
glaciers were like a mile high plus sometimes.
And as they moved across Europe and across North America,
across everywhere on the world.
And at one point in time there's glaciers,
right?
Well,
equatorial region,
70 equator,
right.
The,
the,
what they would do is just completely erase everything that's in front of them.
Yeah.
Because houses,
trees just crush everything rivers
at all.
So anything that died back then that got crushed by this slow moving glacier.
We have nothing.
We have no evidence of it.
That's,
you know,
I've got a book idea that relates to this.
That's a really good point.
I hadn't thought about the glaciers are racing,
stuff like that.
What I thought the book idea is,
you don't remember how Rumsfeld going into a rack said they're the known knowns
and the known unknowns and the unknown.
Uh,
remember that whole thing.
He's don't remember that he gave his press conference and somebody was talking
about predicting what was gonna happen and he said they're the known knowns,
the known unknowns and the unknown unknowns.
So the things you know,
you know,
things you know,
you don't know and the things you don't know that you don't know what.
It's kind of an interesting of shitty idea to go to war with that.
Exactly.
So what I was thinking is write a book about the known unknowns,
the things we know we don't know,
but that we ignore.
Like for example,
in anther anthropology,
archeology,
you're talking about the glaciers wiping out whatever it was there,
which is absolutely the teenagers.
Why about houses?
They would wipe the valley,
you
know,
gone.
Yeah.
So,
um,
it's pretty complete,
you know,
but the other was like,
one,
you know,
people left Africa.
Uh,
the current understanding is about 70,000 years ago and spread out around our
40,000 years ago.
Seventy thousand years ago is the Toba eruption,
which almost wiped out our species.
There were genetic tests show that there were about 3000 couples,
a reproducing couples that have the genetic line has continued.
So there was this huge bottleneck because the lake Toba is now Lake Toba in
Sumatra was this eruption that triggered an immediate ice age and like the feet
of ash all over Asia and just killed everything and triggered winter it was
really nasty.
But anyway,
the,
about 40,000 years ago,
our ancestors left Africa,
the out of Africa,
you know,
event and they spread out around the world,
but they mostly follow the coastline,
right?
Which you would,
right,
because that's where like foods washing up and there's shellfish in there and
you've got good sight lines.
So those bears and leopards and shit,
you'll see them come in,
right?
You can run into the water to get away from him.
And you know,
the,
the sort of,
um,
the water that's not too deep,
you don't have sharks,
but it's deep enough to keep the leopards away.
Right,
right.
Um,
so that's,
and it's easier to walk on the beach,
right?
So that's,
that was the root of the huge exodus that went around the world,
but sea levels were about 300 feet lower than.
Whoa.
So the stuff they're finding,
you know,
the whatever the stone tools or the remains that there,
they're finding from a 30,
40,000 years ago,
those weren't typical at all.
The typical people were down on the beach.
So those must have been hunting parties or people who were exiled or whatever.
But they weren't at all typical.
That's interesting.
So I bet we're missing a lot of the fossils and the little bits of evidence of
those people that lived on the beach,
which was the majority of the people.
And that's the stuff that's a representative.
So it's pretty weird to build your image of a society based on evidence that you
know,
is extraordinary,
you know,
but that's what we do because that's all we got.
I can remember really clearly being in college,
uh,
thinking about human history,
um,
I,
I don't remember what the subject of the class was,
but then I remember being in class and just getting an idea just for the first
time,
but in,
in very roughly of how little we know about just what the fuck actually happened
when you really start reading books about events and,
you know,
I'm reading about like I was reading about custer's last stand and um,
the,
the account of the Indians account and the survivors account and know,
trying to piece it all together.
I'm like,
well,
how crazy is it?
Is really difficult to piece this together in my head.
You know,
but today I can watch September happened or I can watch a plane hit the tower.
I can look the way we have recorded things today is so vastly more intricate
that when I look at what I know of,
you know,
jfk getting shot,
what I know of seeing troops in Vietnam,
like this history that is,
you know,
that I think of when you look at how little we know about 10,000 years ago,
30,000 years ago,
40,000 years ago,
and then the idea that the only way you find things as if people died in like a
volcano or a mud slide because you got to get a fossil or fell into a peat bog.
It's like how many people fall into peat bogs?
How much,
you know,
not enough fucking crazy.
What if all the smart people just rotted in the ground and then go into this
fucking bug?
It was a whole race of super intelligent people that never went into peat bogs
ever.
You know,
the earth.
The first neanderthal remains that were found,
um,
were like hunched over and sort of deformed.
And so for a long time,
the image of a neanderthal was this deformed crazy.
Turns out that was like a really diseased individual,
right?
It wasn't a typical neanderthal.
Listen,
it isn't a typical data finding them very damaged,
especially their spines.
And like there's a lot of times they're really fun.
A lot of.
Yeah,
a lot of hunting accidents and also apparently a lot of wear and tear on the
teeth and stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would imagine.
Yeah.
And,
or tunnels.
Yeah.
Anyway.
It's um,
it's just,
it's really strange.
I,
I've often said that human beings today,
it's almost like waking up in the middle of history as a person,
as an individual.
I've felt that way sometimes watching a documentary or reading a book about
something or trying to imagine what it's been like several hundred years ago.
It's like,
all this has happened already and it's all real clear.
You can sort of piece it together and go.
And then we got here and it's like we woke up,
we woke up and go,
we're,
where are we?
Where are we?
Where on earth.
Okay.
How do we get to earth?
Well,
this is what we've calculated and they lay out a piece of paper,
okay,
earth is near the sun and the sun is surrounded by this other planets.
Does another earth Muslim maybe?
Probably most likely.
Actually it's infinite.
So every possibility will exist.
Infinite numbers of times.
That's the real infinite.
So we're like,
okay,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And then someone goes,
hey man,
I figured some shit out.
It's called quantum theory and you're like,
what the fuck are you saying?
And then dude,
there's gorillas.
You'd go to the jungle,
they found fucking gorilla.
They're big,
they're black,
they're sorta human.
Like get the fuck Outta here.
I'm telling you,
there's monsters out there.
Like all that was,
that's the 18 hundreds.
I mean they didn't,
they didn't.
The Western world didn't know the existence of gorillas until the 18 hundreds.
So it's kind of fascinating when you really think of like where we are right now
and how,
how much we know about how we got here
and you and you didn't know Bonobos till the 19 seventies,
you know,
are really start studying.
I mean,
they thought they were just a sub species of chimp.
They called them pigmeat.
Chimps.
Turns out they're so completely different from chimps that they.
They've forced us to completely reevaluate the primate origins of human beings.
Yeah.
It really threw a monkey wrench in the whole explanation of why we're so warring
and horrible violent.
Want to do that?
I swear to God,
no pun intended,
but the functional note Banabos are like Super Sexual.
They,
they solve everything with sex and the sex.
They don't have as the mother doesn't have sex with a son.
Man.
You did your homework.
Now I've just been fascinated by monkeys.
My whole life's apes.
Champs.
Sorry.
Mostly Champs.
But other apes as well.
Uh,
but yeah,
apes.
I know monkey sounds cooler though,
among gender.
Transgender monkeys have tails.
That's your right.
Monkey balls is such a good phrase,
you know.
I mean,
I use it all the time even though I'm always talking about eight balls,
but the eight ball just doesn't ring.
Yeah.
That's why I.
my one of my comedy specialist was talking monkeys in space because talking apes
in space just didn't.
Yeah.
It's missing something in Spanish.
There's no word for Ayp,
actually real,
which makes things complicated in translating our book to Spanish.
So is it just primates?
Various premium names.
Simeon.
That's it.
That's another good one.
Yeah.
The monkey,
the monkey wrench.
That was thrown in though to get back to the bonobos.
Bonobos are not violent.
They don't.
They don't kill other Benobos then they just fuck all the time.
Friends do all the great Dutch primatologist who's responsible for bringing
Benobos to public light to a large extent.
He said chimps use violence to get sex,
but no booze.
Use Sex to avoid violence.
And bonobos are very interesting and as you know,
people understand the chimps and Bonobos are our two closest primate relatives
by far and in fact there we're more closely related to them then they are to any
other primates.
So if you go to a zoo and you're looking at it,
you know chimp cage,
that champ is more shares,
more DNA with you than he does with a gorilla or an orangutan or anything,
right?
Yeah.
So in fact,
jared diamond wrote a book called the third chimpanzee where he argued that
humans,
chimps and Bonobos are basically three subspecies of chimpanzee,
were so closely related,
were more closely related to them than an Indian elephant is to an African
elephant.
Right.
We're like super close in terms of DNA.
So they're.
But they're very close to each other.
So I think of it as like if I've got twin brothers,
they're closest to each other,
but after each other comes me and I'm equally related to each of them.
So the champ,
as you say,
it's kind of bad ass kind of very male dominated,
very hierarchical,
kind of conflictive can be really nasty,
you know,
rip people's faces off in Connecticut.
But the Bonobo in 50 years of observation in the wild and in captivity,
no one has ever seen Urbanova kill or rape and other Banaba that'll have to
rape.
They just fuck they don't do it.
If you want to not get raped,
just give it up every way you look.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah,
we can never live like them.
I'd say.
I do not agree with that.
I'm just saying it in,
in the animal world,
that's what they do,
right?
I mean,
that's where they,
they never killed a rapist.
Very interesting.
When you're talking about animals,
like a lot of people say that orangutan sex is rape because the male chases the
female through the tree tops and she's screaming and apparently trying to get
away.
Right?
That's a dolphin three isn't.
There is a indication of Dolphin rave with dolphins are also involved in mass
genocide.
Infanticide rather killed baby dolphins.
They kill them to get the females to breed.
That's typical of,
of uh,
a lot of mammals learning ends.
Do that,
do this,
do that.
When there's an Alpha male gorillas when there's an Alpha male and he takes
over,
often he'll kill the.
Or if there's a coalition,
they'll kill the babies to get them back.
The women back into estrous.
It's brutal.
In fact,
that's one of the theories,
Sarah Hrdy,
who's written widely,
she's very well known primatologist anthropologist.
One of,
um,
the theories is that the reason that females are promiscuous in some primate
species is to confuse paternity so that males won't be tempted to kill babies in
order to get women back into a female back into estrous.
And that's the current thinking on dolphins as well.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Dolphin females are known to be like the slots of the ocean.
They have sex,
sex as many guys as possible.
So the guy comes over,
he goes,
yeah.
So while they have that bond with that person,
what do they establish as the main reason why the chimpanzees and Bonobos
though?
So genetically similar,
so different behaviorally.
That's a really good question.
The,
there's no perfect theory.
The best known theory is that,
um,
the chimps and Bonobos,
we're the same species and there was a change in the Congo,
the,
the root of the Congo River,
I think about 5 million years ago and that's been verified.
And uh,
so one population got isolated on the south side of the Congo and the other on
the north and the ones on the south became Benobos.
The ones on the north became chimps.
And the idea,
and this is um,
Richard Wrangham at Harvard proposed this idea,
is that the chimps on the north,
we're competing with gorillas for some of the same food sources,
whereas there are no gorilla south of Congo,
so the Banabos weren't competing for those food sources,
so they didn't have to get gangster.
Right?
But the problem with that theory is that it basically dismisses the assumptions
of Darwinian evolution based on Malthus,
which is that any population
will quickly grow to the point where the,
where the food resources are saturated.
And so you get competition between individuals for whatever's there,
right?
He seems to be saying the population of Banabos never grew to the point where
they were competing for food,
therefore they never had to get competitive.
If that's true,
that's a radical statement.
It happens to be a statement I agree with.
I've made the same statement about early humans.
I'm saying,
hey,
early humans were like,
you know,
these pythons that are introduced into the everglades.
They're like,
whoa,
there's nothing else here competing for this niche.
Well,
it kind of makes sense if you really think about it in terms of how we look at
socialism,
because what are the number one complaint from manly man about socialism?
It's going to make a soft,
which are fucking pussies have just socialists out there yet.
That's the idea.
The idea is to soften everybody the fuck up to reduce the need of competition
and to a lot of people,
especially people that have adopted sort of a advantageous positions,
they look at that as like,
Hey,
fucking plus age,
you gotta earn it.
You know,
socialism is the idea.
It sort of makes sense if you look at the buffalo community,
right?
Yeah.
They didn't have competition so everybody just chilled out and they developed a
style of being that's more chilled out.
Right,
right.
It is a great story.
I'll tell you a guy you should interview.
I think I mentioned him last time.
Robert Sapolsky.
I tried.
I'm trying.
He's in the middle of teaching.
Oh,
okay.
So you've been in touch
for sure.
I learned everything about toxo plasma,
which this podcast is for him to death and they got so tired of talking about
today.
Do you,
do you tell the same story?
Sometimes?
Yeah.
Sometimes I get tweets from people like,
dude,
great,
love your podcast,
but you told that story three times.
Like how do you keep track?
It's really hard when you're having a guest if the guest is not aware of the
information because I don't want to like write it down and say,
okay,
when the podcast is over I got to tell you about
the changes the way you behave.
Um,
so sometimes if it's a new gas and they don't know about it,
I kinda,
I'm sort of forced to.
I tried to give them the cliff notes version of it.
I know about it.
So pasky had an amazing video,
um,
where he detailed and it even went into that when he was a med student.
They would find a cadaver's like guys who died on motorcycles and there was a
disproportionate amount of them that tested positive for toxoplasma takers,
risk takers,
that the parasite literally gets you to take risks.
And that there's a direct correlation between toxo plasma infestation and
successful soccer teams.
Wow.
So they all have cats in the locker room.
No.
Well,
this is two thoughts behind that.
One is it could be purely,
that doesn't cause it's not,
it's not in the fact that's just a correlation correlation in that it's just,
you're dealing with people that live in impoverished areas.
People in impoverished areas have higher incidents of cats,
hired incidences of feral cats is more likely toxoplasma that they're also more
desperate and maybe more invested in soccer and more aggressive in their
approach because it means so much to them because it's a way out,
you know,
much like impoverished people in America sometimes,
they,
they make some of the greatest athletic stories or someone who came from nothing
and was so never wanted to go back to that again and had so much drive.
So I don't know if he can act absolutely connected two of them together.
But it is a fascinating theory.
You
talking about taking risks.
Uh,
as I've gotten older,
I've developed this concept I call the bucket list.
So the,
you know,
the bucket list is stuff you want to do before you die.
Right.
But like I turned 51 a couple of weeks ago and I'm at the stage now where I've
got a fuck it list were things I used to think I wanted to do before I die.
And now I'm like,
yeah,
fuck it.
You know,
like one g jumping.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck it.
That's definitely on a fucking noisy.
Yeah.
I'll show you a video.
A Guy Bungee jumps in his,
his cord was not long enough.
Slice slams off the ground in agony.
And then with the body he has court is too long ago with his broken body slams
off the ground again and it does like several times he's got like a helmet
camera in the screens and he makes are horrific.
He didn't die.
He lived because it slowed him down a little bit,
but I mean it just broke him and then spring up in the air and then smashed back
down again.
I mean,
I don't know if he lived after the video,
but he's alive during the video and it'll cure.
You have any ideas of bungee jumping?
I hope it wasn't Antosz point.
Oh,
you probably covered it.
He's probably got a fucking 10 minutes of his act about it.
Really?
Yeah.
He's,
he's covered everything.
Fucked up.
That's ever been released on the young Turks.
He's in the same building.
Oh,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I,
I did a show with Doug Stanhope recently who went and we did this thing where it
was a guy who was a lifelong virgin trying to give them advice,
but a bucket list.
That's a good one for the bucket list.
Punchkick just bungee jumping.
Skydiving.
I could be convinced to skydive if it was with some friends.
Fuck No.
Tell him.
Tell him the story.
My Dad was this girl that my dad worked with skydived all the time and every
know she always tried to get him to do it.
So finally he was going to do it and then like a week before you're supposed to
do it.
Uh,
she jumped and heard a chute,
didn't open,
and then the reserve chute start tangling with the other shooter and then she
died.
So it's like my dad was supposed to do it like the following week or something.
We can add that to the fuck.
Fuck it.
That's all she did it.
She was a pro.
It was just,
you know,
a bad shoot.
I did a hair a.
I always forget Paris lighting.
What's the difference?
Parasailing is behind a boat,
right?
Yeah.
No I do paragliding.
Jumping off a mountain.
Oh my God.
I did this in indy.
I took,
it was really dumb but cheap.
It was cheap.
It was.
So it's your life.
It was in Goa and there's this German guy on the beach where I was staying in
this Hippie beach and go,
uh,
called Aaron Bull.
Whereas Gola go as a,
the just below Mumbai in India.
It's on the west coast of India and it's like this legendary hippy place like
Philips since the sixties.
Hippies have been going there to chill out on these amazing beaches and small
cash and you know,
do yoga and shit.
So I was there for 10 years ago or something and you know,
we were there for two weeks,
two months on this beach.
Like I didn't wear shoes for two months,
it was just so great and so I was looking for stuff to do and there's this
German guy who have a who was teaching,
you know,
you do these classes and it was like for 10 jumps,
100 bucks or something.
So I signed up and you do the first day theory and you learn like learn some
weird shit.
Like there are these cloud formations,
it'll suck you up into them and when you're like in the cloud you don't know
what's up and what's down.
And so there are all these things you like.
It's like instrument control.
You have to like,
even if you think you're falling upward,
you have to pull the shit and fall.
And it's like,
oh,
that's weird and horrible stuff.
What is the cloud formation?
That's sucks you up.
What's that all about?
I don't remember.
I just remember like,
you know,
I will not go near those clouds.
The wizard of Oz type of situation.
It was some,
some particular cloud formation that,
that has a really strong updraft.
It's like,
um,
you know,
what's it called on the beach where you get sucked out to ocean,
the untitled,
like you have to go against it.
Not against it die.
I'm 90 degree angle.
Not trying to get out of it.
Like you don't swim against the undertow,
you swim across the undertone,
right?
Same thing in this case because you get sucked up.
Your body freezes and then they'll find you like far,
far away,
frozen,
solid.
Like it's either the iceman.
Yeah,
we didn't finish the story.
The reason why this guy didn't get smushed is because uh,
he like fell into the bottom of this crevasse and got covered and turned into a
essentially like frozen dinner and a mummy frozen mummy.
So if people like,
what the fuck?
He never finished that story.
Do you know Brad Pitt has a tattoo of it.
See on his arm.
Doesn't really know he's really into etsy.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Why?
I guess he's just super into it.
So,
you know,
maybe we'd have to ask Brad Pitt.
You've got a better chance of getting them on the phone the night.
I don't think he talked to me.
I fell.
Oh Shit I've talked about is perfume ads is it looks bad ass,
world war z and maybe those perfume man's fucking do it for me though.
Have seen them now.
Might be the Douchey is commercial world has ever known next to Stephen Dorff
electronic cigarette commercial right there.
Like what?
He needs the money.
Well,
you know,
the only thing that I leave for him,
his maybe he puts that money to use in some positive way.
He's very active.
I know a lot of stuff both in America and abroad,
so it could be that,
you know,
they were going donate a shitload of money to something and he did it,
but it's chanel number five.
It's like such a Dorky,
but it's good to bring this up anyway because I wanted to talk to you about
perfume because it's fucking hilarious.
Where it all came from.
Oh yeah.
I cover.
This stinks.
This is not the green.
That commercial using conjunctive can chunk now.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Put the actual one man.
I don't want to see you.
GotTa you gotTa.
See his stupid face,
I doing it,
uh,
for the.
Yeah,
what's ridiculous.
It's the most ridiculous commercials of all time because it's a guy who's a
fucking multimillionaire millionaire that you noticed and wear the stupid,
Stinky Shit.
His wife as much money as he does and he's done a little chanel number five
commercial and somebody has videos of him sucking a million bucks or something.
That's how they did it.
It's something missing or they,
you know,
they promise to cure aids.
This is,
it really ends.
But we go on.
The world turns.
When we turned with it,
the world turns.
We turned.
Plans disappear.
Dreams take over
whenever I go.
There you are.
I love my faith.
Number five.
That's a fucking goddamn Saturday night live sketch.
Okay.
Wow.
That does seem like a parody of a commercial starring.
It also seems like a parody of tree of life.
Did you see that movie?
Yes.
No,
I didn't know.
That's the Tom Hanks one with Brad Pitt.
It's directed by the guy who did the,
uh,
he's a very interesting directory.
Does like one movie every 10 years or something.
I can't remember his name right now.
This is not the interconnected lives.
What does well,
no,
that's the atlas.
The cloud atlas.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
No,
this,
this is like,
it is really trippy though.
It's like there's all this.
It'll have A.
Brad Pitt is a father,
a couple of kids.
I'm sure most of your listeners know what I'm talking about it.
He's a well known director.
He did a really funky movie about the Pacific Theater,
World War Two with Sean Penn in it.
Um,
and,
and um,
and uh,
the guy from Saturday night fever,
a gay guy bathhouses dare you,
the gay guy.
How about the amazing dancer,
like a really talented actor from pulp fiction
suck dick and nanosecond to know who is talking about.
You were playing charades.
I would applaud.
Anyway.
Yeah.
So that was,
that seemed like a parody of that movie.
There it is,
like the sun bursting and there's this real slow visuals and yeah,
I don't know what the fucking motivation was,
but it's preposterous.
Just completely ridiculous commercial.
The idea behind the perfume itself,
it's very fascinating though.
I don't like it.
I've never liked it.
I don't mean there's like a couple like oils that girls can put on.
I think that smells kind of cool,
but generally I like the way people smell in a clean,
you know,
and that's why perfume was invented.
People weren't fucking clean,
they were dirty,
stinking animals that we're scared of water.
And that's also why spices were so valuable during those centuries of the spice
spices.
Pepper black pepper was worth more than because the food was rotting so they
would spice the shit up.
So you couldn't taste.
How horrible did a lot of people die from horrible digestive issues back then?
Uh,
well yeah.
In the medieval period,
a lot of people were dying from all sorts of nastiness related to the nastiness
of the food,
but also the fact that they were shitting in the street and there's no sewage
and everything.
But what's interesting,
I think this is like cutting edge medical research.
Is that thing still playing in the background?
In the background there?
Yeah,
I've heard it since the movie was on just now.
What is the for your ipad?
You Fuck Jesus.
Brian.
I thought I was going crazy again.
Uh Oh.
Is it cutting edge medical research I think is going to.
You're probably tuned into this because of the body hacking and all that.
The,
the microflora of the stomach.
Yeah.
Really interesting.
So in those days people would have had really robust,
uh,
intestinal flora to deal with all that.
The bacteria that you're absorbing your system on a daily basis,
which dogs have supply dogs drink water and people who live in India.
And you know,
I spent a lot of time and I went swimming in a fucking lake in India.
I don't know what I was.
Do not have the science channel.
No.
Do not have discovery.
Do you not watch those things where people come back with fucking football sized
parasites growing inside of their head do this,
was,
this was a long time ago and I,
I was young and invincible,
but a lot of stupid shit.
Nothing.
You Got Lucky and I've been healthy as shit,
you know,
I'm like the guy who never gets sick.
Maybe that's what it is.
I.
Well,
I think honestly,
I,
when I was traveling a lot in Asia and Latin American stuff,
I took a lot of acidophilus and raw garlic.
Talk about body smells,
man.
I ate so much raw garlic and uh,
and the raw garlic is good.
It keeps him skeeto so away they don't like the smell of garlic and it comes out
through your skin.
It keeps women away too.
I found I'm not Italian women.
Yeah.
This is accepted Italian men.
Keep the Italian.
But uh,
yeah.
And I say that,
but the ball show a different story.
Are we going to put our balls on the table?
Italian balls.
The balls are large.
They're the director.
I think it's more of a species.
I mean there is some cultural,
there is evidence that Asian balls are smaller.
Um,
I am started talking Spanish.
They're quite a bit smaller than a black balls and white balls or somewhere in
the middle
being very sort of.
I don't know if that's politically incorrect to say,
but it's,
it seems to be true.
And my wife has,
I don't think I told you this story last time because Sylvia was here last time,
um,
couple of years into our relationship.
Uh,
one night we were hanging out with a friend in Barcelona smoking a joint and,
and uh,
this friend,
he's a funny guy,
he was giving me a hard time by giving her a hard time essentially.
And so he was saying about,
Kyla,
you're so innocent,
you know,
you were in medical school and then you were married all these years and you
know,
you hook up with Chris when you're 40,
you know,
you're just starting to see the world as Chris's corrupting you.
Right.
And he said,
you're so innocent,
you probably think Chris has a big Dick.
And she said,
well,
no,
I,
I've inspected a thousand penises.
And we were like,
well,
she said,
yeah.
When I was doing that research for the World Health Organization in Africa,
I had to inspect the thousand penises and Vaginas.
It turns out.
I mean,
I knew she had done this research,
but I didn't know it involved actually holding the Cox,
you know?
Yeah.
And so we loved to no gloves,
gloves,
because account then sort of counts.
It doesn't matter me.
I mean if I were going to be uptight about shit like that,
believe me,
I'd be in a different business,
but a,
the funny thing was he was like,
but you know,
she's hot and she was 27 or something at the time.
And you're like,
what about erections?
And she just laughed and she said,
Oh yeah,
you just flick.
So Casella sort of like the anti fluffer she knows how to bring it down.
There's like you flick right under the head and the erection is gone
immediately.
Really try it when you get home.
Sounds annoying just to annoy the shit out of him.
But somewhere out there there's a guy that wouldn't stop me.
I like a little flicking.
So,
uh,
so she can prove she's one of the rare individuals that seeing the broad
spectrum of the racist.
And she says,
well,
she seen a thousand Africans.
It's all apps.
That was all an hour.
Okay.
So it was all African people.
So it's a thousand Africans and me,
that's her,
her pool.
Oh yeah,
she's not impressed.
I haven't asked.
I don't even ask.
I don't want to know the answer.
That's funny.
What a Douche bag friend you have,
by the way.
I would cut that guy off just the way it communicates.
Is he a dickhead?
He's a strange dude actually.
He's a jazz musician who went to,
grew up and went to college in Philadelphia at Temple,
which is 98 percent black and he's white.
I'm Jewish.
He's like a hairy dark skin,
Jewish guys,
big tall guy.
And he talks like an inner city Philadelphia black dude and he sounds wonderful,
but he,
he's not doing it.
He's not racist.
Like he just,
he grew up with these guys and,
and you know,
you learn to sort of communicate the way your community communicate.
But it could be awkward because he would,
you know,
as much as he would use the n word liberally.
Really?
Yeah.
Among like a white crowd or,
and with his black friends who knew him,
but then it would get weird if we were at a party or something and he'd be like,
Yo,
mom was like a fucking idiot.
What are you hanging out with this guy for a long time?
Making fun of you
for having a regular size to your wife.
What?
Did douchebag dropping bombs.
Yeah,
bring them to my parties.
sounds like a treat.
He knows I love white guys who talk black to.
Oh,
one of my favorite things.
Can't get enough of them in my life.
That's what you really want to go to.
If you're really confused about the world.
He needs a confidant.
Need someone?
Yeah.
You to go to a white guy who talks black.
Yeah,
but I mean it happens.
Hey,
look at all these kids with their pants hanging down around their asses and
showing gang signs and you know,
flicker photos and what are you doing?
That pants
hanging around your.
Your ass means one thing.
You don't know how to check leg kicks because I guarantee you one more tie at
all.
You wouldn't have your fucking pants hamper.
Your someone who's just going to kick your legs.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Your buckles over your Dick.
He can't move your hips.
Right?
Going to get into,
what did you say?
Look at those kids with their baggy pants and their liquor photos,
the gang signs and their flicker for the gang signs in their flicker,
flicker.
They really put the gang signs online and you see these kids from Pacific
palisades.
It's like
there is an issue with that.
Those kids that grow up in those really rich places where they want to
overcompensate because of the fact that their parents are so not street and they
get like inner mixed with inner city kids.
They get shipped there and then they want to prove their worth and I actually
had a friend who had a kid who went to a,
one of those Pacific Pacific palisades or Malibu,
but one of those high schools and he's like,
you'd be fucking amazing how bad it was.
They had to pull the kid out of there because there's constant drugs and
violence and chaos and craziness and the all a massive amount of kids in those
areas that grow up.
And I.
It kind of makes sense if you think about it,
is people that have a fuckload of money,
a lot of them also,
they have issues with pills where they have pills at home or um,
there,
there's a shallow sort of,
um,
materialistic vibe to the family and uh,
it gets,
it gets distributed to the kids and then the kids start doing a lot of pills.
It's like it was Malibu or one of those high schools.
I can't really wish I could remember,
but they were snorting oxies.
It was like a big issue.
You
know,
I've heard about that in thousand oaks too,
that they have a problem with the girls.
Dylan has been quite a few girls that have gotten in trouble for doing
oxycontin's.
They're doing heroin and they're doing it in high school and these are really
wealthy neighborhoods,
wealthy areas.
But these people probably never around for their fucking kids.
And if you've got enough money to buy $9,000,000 house,
you work your Dick off,
you know,
you probably are not around that much.
Yeah.
I don't see how kids are raised by Nannies.
Many cases.
Yeah.
Especially in those dual career household when your wife works her ass off as
well,
you're both working your ass off all day and then you're trying to become
parents at night and it's a fucking grind.
That's a hard grind.
You know,
if you leased a lot of poor people,
they involve their families in that grind,
you know,
they bring in the grandmother or you know,
they live in a neighborhood where a lot of family members nearby and they can
sort of take turns taking care of all the children together,
which actually turned out to be healthier as long as it's not a high crime area
on that.
See that relates back to three history.
Yeah.
You know,
this whole idea and Kasota grew up in Mozambique and she talked about like,
you know,
at night and nobody worried about where you were.
Your parents didn't worry about where you are wherever you were.
Somebody there are some adults,
they're taking care of you being cool,
you know,
you could eat dinner at somebody else's house and come home later or sleep
there.
You look for like whatever.
It sounds.
So unity,
Utopian.
Yeah.
But yet,
not because nobody wants to live in Mozambique,
you know,
no one here happened in math.
You say that,
oh,
but it's the Brazil in Beverly Hills and say,
Hey,
who wants to go to Mozambique?
They going to go,
bitch,
are you crazy?
I'm not going to move to Mozambique.
I speech and you're like,
you could just let your kids go and no one needs to worry.
Like,
fuck you.
What are you going to let your kids go at night in Africa?
Are you fucking crazy?
No one's gonna believe that's the truth,
man.
So what is it like you said,
it's like the Brazil.
I haven't been to Mozambique.
So you're talking shit,
I'm talking shit.
But my wife grew up there so I hear a lot about it and she was just there a
couple months ago and she said,
and it's like eight percent economic growth.
It's Africa is booming right now because the Chinese are buying up all the
natural resources that buying up land.
It's,
it's happening.
Wow.
Yeah.
In Mozambique's,
you know,
famous for their amazing beaches and seafood.
And it's,
it's like a pretty raw,
beautiful spot on earth.
Wow.
Yeah.
Africa is a trip you fucking place,
man.
The idea of leaving the kids just wandering around and Africa are two lions and
Mozambique.
Yeah.
In fact,
she had a.
She had a German shepherd
who got that got eaten by a lion when she was a kid.
Rice.
Yeah.
Mountain lions are scary lions way scarier than mountain lion.
Nobody gets away from the lines.
But you know what kills most people in Africa?
Hippo fucking ants over.
Really answer a motherfucker.
That's not a good way to.
There's video.
I saw once of ants eating an elephant and they were going up the elephant's leg
into its ear.
Oh No.
And they were essentially attacking this elephant,
eating an ear first,
just going right through the ear.
And there wasn't a Goddamn thing the elephant can do to stop it.
Oh man,
that's not in Alaska.
You get that with mosquito.
Yeah,
I've seen that on a horrible.
I've never experienced it live,
but I've watched those,
um,
those Alaska sustenance shows those.
Um,
have you ever seen those shows?
Saw one or two.
Yeah.
Where they put these like a reality.
No,
no,
no.
These are actually people that live there.
They're uh,
they're these people that.
There's a bunch of different ones.
There's one of them's called Yukon man and the other one's called Alaska,
the last frontier and,
and they're essentially these people that live in these very small hunting
communities,
hunting fishing communities,
and they make no income other than furs that they occasionally get and they have
three months of summer where they're all just frantically trying to gather up
resources and then they locked down for seven,
eight,
nine months.
It's crazy to watch.
And these people in the summertime,
they're dealing with fucking swarms of mosquitoes,
like aggressive,
desperate mosquitoes.
They're like an inch across and they know they only have a couple of months so
they just go for it.
Yeah,
I remember,
you know when the dusk,
when the mosquitoes come out and you can see a swarm,
you're setting up your tent,
you know.
And like,
I remember setting up my tent and like every second moving my shirts so they
couldn't get in through the shirt,
you know,
I had to keep moving the shirt while I'm setting up the tent.
And then you get in there and you can hear.
It's like hail banging against the side of the tenant.
You can hear them banging on the tent.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
they're,
they're little helicopter.
What the fuck did people do before they figured out tense?
Uh,
well the Eskimos,
I believe that they smeared fat on their skin that would,
certain kinds of fat would keep the mosquitoes off them and they've got all
sorts of really clever adaptations,
you know,
we,
we sort of assume that we would be helpless,
but that's because we didn't grow up there and our culture didn't,
you know.
So there's,
you know who Wade Davis is a,
he's a,
he's an anthropologist.
He's written a bunch of books.
Really interesting guy.
He's like anthropologists in residence at the Smithsonian in Washington.
He wrote a book called the wayfarers I think was his last book about
traditional,
like,
about how these guys could navigate across the Pacific,
just looking at the stars and the color of the water and smelling and whatever
they'd.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
one of the stories he tells us about this,
Eskimo guy,
old guy and the family sort of took the keys to the car away from him.
Like you can't go anymore.
They were afraid he would go out and die the traditional way when Eskimo people
got old,
they would like wander off into the ice and die.
So as not to be a burden to the family.
Right.
And he was a traditional guy and they were worried that he would take the snow
machine out and just die out there somewhere or hurt himself hunting or
whatever.
So they had this whole intervention.
And so that night he goes out,
gets out of the house,
takes a shit in his hand,
forms the shit into a knife,
blade spits on it and the spit is freezing along the edge and he hones that
down.
So he gets a nice sharp edge with his sped,
takes his shit knife,
kills a dog or a couple of dogs and takes their ribs and makes us a sled out of
it.
And with the sinews and whatever other pieces of the dogs,
you know,
he knew all this stuff from his childhood,
hooks up a couple of other dogs to the sled and he takes off into this,
into the snow on his,
you know,
sled with his shit knife.
Wow.
Oh my God.
That might be the most of the same story I've ever heard.
And they're so clever.
You know how they killed polar bears.
I know they take blood and put it on a blade.
I know that method.
That was actually wolves.
The wolves would lick the blade and uh,
we would,
uh,
they would cut themselves to death,
similar kind of thing.
What they would do is they take a little,
they'd make a wooden box and they would take a seal,
a rib and sharpen the two ends of the seal rib.
And they're pretty flexible.
They bend it and stick it into the box,
right?
And then they'd pour melted fat into the box and let it solidify freeze and then
they knock it out.
So you've got a fat cube with this flexed to bladed thing inside it.
And they leave that in the snow.
Polar bear come along,
swallow it,
and opens in the polar bear.
Wow.
And they just follow the blood drops and it would kill them.
Yeah.
Because internal hemorrhaging.
How long did it take to kill him?
I Dunno,
I just remember that.
I mean,
there are stories like that all over the world.
You know,
the Indian monkey trap,
the East Indian monkey.
No,
I don't know how interested your readers or your listeners that system is.
And this is a good metaphor to.
I always remember this one.
They would take,
um,
same thing,
take a box with a hole about a little smaller than a fist in the Mug,
in the box.
And they put a mango in the box and then hammer it shot and tight to a tree.
So the mango starts rotting,
the monkey smells it.
Monkey comes along,
can stick his hand in and feel the mango,
but he can't get his hand out as long as he's holding onto the mango and they
won't let go of the mango.
All they have to do is let go and they could leave,
but they've got the mango in their hands and they won't let go.
And so the guy comes around to check the traps.
There's the monkey standing there with his hand in the box.
Hit It on the head.
You got your monkey.
Whoa.
So it was something about greed there.
That's an awesome story.
That is a perfect metaphor to.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
Wow.
Let go of the mango.
That's my advice.
Yeah,
that's a good.
That should be a t shirt.
Not a bumper sticker.
A bumper sticker.
Bad showed good shit.
It's a better bumper.
He said Shit.
Knife is a crazy story.
The guy killed a dog with a frozen piece of shit.
How stupid was that?
Dog
was sleeping there.
This guy came up,
my man,
he got shit,
man.
What the fuck are you doing?
Dogs Love Shit.
Where you at?
Where are you going to talk people into shitting in their hand or stuff like
that.
Wasn't that one of your,
um,
I forgot I did.
I talked to you about this.
No,
no.
Um,
I believe you talked to Duncan.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
We were talking about um,
about wiping,
wiping yourself and about how weird it is that we sort of like smudge tissue
over our assholes after we shit.
And then in other countries that we consider these people to be savage,
they wash their hand,
you know,
and they wash their ass with their hand and water and we'd like that.
It's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
exactly.
And it's the reason why your left hand is the inappropriate hand to shake hands
with and already in the Arab and.
Yeah.
And that they,
they always clean with their left hand.
The Shit experiment.
Did you actually make people do that?
I didn't know.
Know what happened.
I pussied out to fucking Ted again to ted get involved with bitches.
No balls.
No Shit.
You're out of here.
Do you want in the call?
Yes or no?
It just took down a couple more videos recently of WHO's here,
I'll find it,
but then they put the hancock and sheldrake ones back up on the different part
of the site.
He ever took them down.
Totally.
They took them off of one part and they put it on another part and they put it
up with a disclaimer because they felt like that there was poor science.
There was bad,
so pseudo science,
which if if the scientists can prove it makes sense,
but I think that if you.
You're going to invite someone to talk and you're going to say that they have
pseudoscience.
I said at the very least you should allow them to have a,
an appropriate response or allow them to a debate.
You know them on the merits of this science.
Exactly.
Because I don't know who's right or who's wrong.
Well,
the anonymous scientific panel that they use,
that's what I think is bullshit because they've got a lot of mainstream people
who are going to say,
you know,
whatever Iowasca is bullshit,
but you know,
let let sheldrake debate that.
Or in that case it was hancock.
I think he was talking about Iowasca,
you know,
or get a Andrew Weil who's an expert,
ms or a way Davis Actually Wade Davis and Andrew,
while we're both graduate students,
have Richard Evans
shelties,
who was probably the most important
bio,
sorry,
botanist of the 20th century.
He's the one who discovered the plants behind and named the plants behind
Iowasca and La.
He did his graduate work on God.
He never.
He was a very sort of straight guy himself.
He never took any of this stuff,
but he discovered dozens of psychoactive plants in the Amazon.
He was down there like 20 years
years.
That sounds all great.
I mean,
that's absolutely great for expanding people's knowledge on the subject,
but in their particular situation,
what was kind of disturbing was that on the website of Ted,
the accusations that they had or the reasons that they had for censoring
Hancock's work,
he asked them specifically site where I said,
this site where I apply this,
this is not what I said.
So he was saying that they sort of made this justification that didn't sort of
jive with his talk.
Now Rupert Sheldrake,
who I think is a bit more controversial in his,
his statements,
what,
what Hancock is trying to say is that Iowasca has had this profound effect on
humanity and it's based on his own actual personal experiences taking it,
the experiences of other people that have taken it.
The I,
the idea being that this indigenous population was not the only peoples that
have discovered psychedelic plants,
but then in fact there's a cave art that details people in altered states of
consciousness also details what they believe to be certain psychedelic
substances and that it's most likely responsible for a lot of art.
Um,
and I think that's a pretty reasonable thing to say.
And if you don't think it's reasonable,
the only thing I could say is I doubt you've had any psychedelic experiences
because psychedelic experiences would be incredibly profound to monitor
primitive man and to state any best.
Seems to me that you're not being honest.
You're ignorant.
You're either ignorant to the effects of these things or you're not being honest
about the effects of these things because you're worried about the perception
that mainstream academia,
that most people in the media,
when you start talking about mushrooms,
they think you're a silly person.
You're a fool is again,
right?
That's the institution determining the information that's allowed to flow
through that institution.
Yeah.
I interviewed,
um,
Charles grobe a couple of weeks ago who was at Ucla.
He's a psychiatrist at Ucla who uses a silicide and I think he's also used mgma
in psychotherapy with people who have end stage cancer to help them.
It's been very effective in helping them deal with the fear of death because of
the sort of transcendent transcendent experience that often accompanies these
substances.
They feel a sense of union with the university.
They lose a lot of that,
you know,
I'm just my body feeling which helps them deal with death.
So transfer that to what saying about
I'm a hunter gatherer.
People are pre agricultural people around the world or post agricultural people
so much in India and,
and a lot of,
uh,
the,
the ulysses,
you know,
the Elisa and fields in ancient Greeks.
A lot of these rituals were apparently based on,
um,
Amanita Muscarella,
which is a highly hallucinogenic.
It's the red mushroom with the white spots in Alice in wonderland.
And Yeah,
silence,
Santa Claus connection.
Very famous.
Exactly.
The AMANITA Mascara is.
So has that been proven?
Is that.
No,
that's,
it's a theory that was proposed by Gordon Wasson who,
um,
uh,
this is all stuff you can like mind Stanley on Saturday,
he was like,
Stanley met a woman,
the Shaman in Mexico who brought mushrooms into the Western world.
I'm Maria Sabina.
Maria,
I think.
Is there any,
um,
any way that the point I was making is that,
you know,
here's this guy using this stuff to alleviate the fear of death with dramatic
results.
And yet,
as you say,
it's still considered fringe.
Although relating back to our earlier conversation about institutions being in
the state of crisis,
because people sort of recognize the false values and these institutions,
the government finally allowing researchers.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a pretty radical findings.
Uh,
the John Hopkins Study on Psilocybin and behavioral change,
how it just one trip affected people's behavior and personality is positively 20
years later.
And,
and what Hancock was talking about with specifically the effect of some
hallucinogens on addiction.
Yes.
And he was using his own personal addiction to cannabis.
He had a lifelong history of abuse as he called it,
with cannabis.
Say,
sorry to interrupt you,
but just the last point on that I,
I didn't listen to sheldrake's thing,
but I did listen to Hancock and he framed the whole thing in I think very
scientific terms.
He said,
this may have caused this leap forward in consciousness.
This may have been responsible for this and that
it's absolutely a fascinating possibility to consider.
And the only people in my opinion that would not consider it are again,
people that have had no experiences with it or people that were worried about
the mainstream academic approval.
And so they step back and go,
oh,
this is preposterous,
you know,
this is not,
it's an incredibly powerful experience.
It cannot be denied.
And,
and yet for whatever reason,
we've lumped it into silliness and I really,
I struggled with now,
or criminality.
Yes,
even more scary than silliness.
Um,
I've,
uh,
really it's really boggled my mind.
And the only thing that makes sense is that it's ignorance.
It's the illegality of it,
which was a hoist onto the American people in the 19 seventies when they were
just trying to control this mass change in culture that had happened so
radically between the fifties,
the sixties.
And we lost a lot of information in that.
And we also got a lot of people that were scared,
scared about going to jail,
scared about losing their jobs and that all that fear and ignorance clouds the
actual argument.
It clouds the actual facts that surround these weird substances.
And they,
they're not the cure all.
They're not,
they're not,
they're not for everybody.
But what they are is incredibly powerful experiences.
I think that can be denied and to deny the impact of one of the most amazing
trends in dental experiences that a human being can ever possibly experience and
the fact that it's an orally active thing,
that it grows all over the place where these people absolutely lived.
To deny the connection seems really silly.
It doesn't.
It seems like you're.
You're being a fool and you're.
You're ignoring information
and people all over the world who have access to these plants,
wherever you find them,
consider them to be the greatest gift of the gods.
Yes,
and then you've got our culture that says,
if you get caught with an ounce of Siliciden,
mushrooms are 100 hits of acid at a grateful dead show.
You go to prison under minimum mandatory sentencing for longer than second
degree murder.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
That's complete pure insanity that that's insanity,
but what's even more and sanity is to me that people in positions of prominence
academically who will talk on these subjects have not had this experience and
I'm like my God,
your children,
and it sounds so arrogant to say that,
but someone who's like talking about the negative effects of psychedelic drugs
that hasn't had psychedelic drugs will feel like a child after he has a mushroom
chip.
He will feel like a full.
You will feel like you the dumbest person in the world to have ignored that and
Pooh poohed that takes six grams of mushrooms,
get in an isolation tank and tell me you don't have some regrets for how you
look at that shit before.
Right?
They're not having it and it's these.
These are the same people that are pulling these things down.
I guarantee you the people that have had profound mushroom trips are not
interested in,
in,
in silencing this Graham Hancock a war on consciousness,
which originally was called beating.
I think something about the green bitch.
He reasonably could defeating the Green Bitch,
which was his addiction,
cannabis and how the.
The,
the IOWASCA helped him see who he was,
his,
uh,
abusive relationship and it seems really fascinating guy because he's not down
on marijuana at all.
He's sort of attributes it to his own abuse of it and using it as a crutch
instead of using it to enhance,
you know,
so he had whatever addictive issues he had.
That's how they mean that.
And that is a real issue with addiction,
right?
It's like,
it's not necessarily the substance of the biologic triggers what's going on with
you that makes you obsess with scratch tickets.
Who's
The guy?
I'm the British actors,
Guinea comedian.
Really Guy Sleeping with Russell brand,
Russell brand.
Thank you.
Should play.
This is what happens when we get all that back.
I remember the Guy fucking point me my brain,
I'll just stick in the air massage guy likes massages.
Russell brand wrote a thing recently about addiction and he said something I
thought was really wise.
He said drugs weren't my problem,
drugs were my answer to my problem.
Uh,
and it's,
it's exactly what you just said in that.
I agree completely.
Drugs aren't causing the addiction.
You've got an addiction,
it can manifest as you know,
in marijuana,
in gambling and jerking off and you know,
a million different ways and if you locate the problem in the substance then
you'll never solve the problem because that's just a symptom,
right?
There is a physiological issue that goes along with that as well.
So because there's two types of situations,
there's the gambling situation where you're sort of getting addicted to the
response,
but then there's a real like,
like an oxycontin thing.
Like I have a friend who had a back operation and then after his back operation
they throw them on some oxygen and he was fucked up for a long time.
He started getting prescriptions from more than one different doctor and he was
a mess.
He just went,
I just went crazy spiral and it was absolutely a physiological addiction because
before that he really didn't exhibit crazy addictive or impulsive behaviors and
they were manifested itself with these.
But it's situation
changed with that pain and the gambler is also getting a chemical a high.
Yes,
you know,
the brain is releasing endorphins or whatever it is.
And in that case,
so there,
you know,
you could argue they're both physiological on some level,
but yeah,
the point is that there is some,
in his case it was chronic pain.
In another case it could be ptsd,
it could be a fucked up childhood,
it could be whatever.
That is a funny way to look at it that I never think I,
I don't think I ever looked at it that way before that it is still a chemical
addiction.
It's just sort of an endogenous one.
Yeah.
That's funny.
I never thought about it that way.
I was knocked it off
thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
orgasm as people jerk off in front of the computer all day.
They're get there some we're talking to you.
Yeah.
That's you.
That's you,
you motherfucker.
You know you are.
Yeah.
That's.
Well that's also sort of just becomes like impulsive it,
like it was not even a reward sometimes it just,
just sort of repeat a pattern.
Like you're stuck.
You got to scratch her when you stop.
And that's what addiction is.
It hurts when you stopped.
You were talking earlier,
we were talking about primitive so called primitive societies and stuff.
You reminded me of this amazing story I read recently where this BBC team went
into Papa New Guinea way back some river and they were doing a special on these
very so called primitive people back there,
you know,
no Internet,
no nothing.
And one of the guys,
uh,
after they'd finished filming,
one of the guys said,
well,
you've,
we've shown you our world.
Why don't you bring me to your world?
I'd like to see your world.
So when he was back
in London,
he talked to some people and they said,
well,
okay,
we'll fund it.
That would be an interesting thing.
Bring these guys into London and you know,
and do this whole thing sort of in reverse.
What's that?
It's a sitcom.
Yeah,
exactly.
Realities.
Dude's fucking reality shifts.
Take them in London.
Yeah.
So the Jersey shore for the UK.
So,
so this guy,
his concern was that once this guy saw the modern world,
he would never want to go home.
So he called up an anthropologist and he said,
look,
I'm really worried about this.
I'd like to do this,
but.
And the anthropologists send you arrogant asshole.
You really think this guy's going to be so impressed by London that he'd never
want to go back to his friends and family and you know,
his whole world and all that just calm down.
That's not going to happen.
Right?
Trust.
So they fly this guy,
if you guys up to London or they take them all around,
show them,
you know,
whatever,
all these different things.
And one of the things they really wanted to see was something like a,
an archery range.
So they took them to this archery range and they were so fascinated by the
arrows that had feathers on the era of the flushings.
Yeah.
Their feathers didn't have arrows.
Arrows in the federal.
Sorry,
there's didn't have feathers.
So anyway,
at the end of this whole experience of being in London,
the only thing they wanted to take back was this knowledge of how you put the
feathers on the air.
They weren't interested in.
No.
At the worlds.
That story is that London ain't Tahiti,
Tahiti,
anthropologists,
and be like,
yeah,
they're not going
to get him on his shit.
Drunk white leg paper eating fish and chips.
They're gonna.
Want to get the fuck out of there as quickly as they got their
new kitties.
That trip,
man,
[inaudible] New Guinea has those semen warriors.
That's one of the weirdest and I was going to bring that up earlier when we were
talking about these patterns that sort of develop in these tribal societies.
One of the most bizarre ones is these,
they take young boys away from their mother when they're like six or seven and
they live with men that are the like an anal father and anal son like that's how
they.
They they,
they call it and the man just fucks these kids and they.
They believe that the kid has to swallow and ingest semen into his body in order
for him to grow up strong and be a man and that they only use women for,
for procreation or that this entire culture of thousands of people is wrapped
around little kids,
sucking guys dicks to grow old to grow strong.
Fucking.
That is.
That is one of the craziest ones I've ever written or read rather than.
Yeah,
that somehow or another they convinced thousands of people
into that one.
But what's the of that?
Oh,
who knows?
You know,
they don't want nobody to know,
but you find stuff like that motherfucker.
Just
one pope can just ruin a whole damn religion.
Maybe they were missionaries because you know that happened in the Amazon.
There's a case of Liza was his name.
He's a French missionary.
He was the,
or an anthropologist.
He wasn't a missionary is an anthropologist who studied under a,
the great French,
a Levy Strauss,
and he went to the Yanomami people in Venezuela and he was fucking all the boys
and doing all this crazy shit and telling them that this was the way it worked
in the world.
And you know,
he's still there.
I think he's still alive.
This part of the whole holy and Shag non situation.
I don't know if you're familiar with that.
Yeah.
It's very controversial stuff that happened.
Uh,
Shannon is,
he wrote the fierce people,
which is the best selling anthropology book of all time.
And he was like a Hemingway Kinda guy.
And he just published a book recently talking about trying to redeem his
reputation because it turns out like what he did was he went to the Amazon in
the late sixties,
uh,
or the Orinoco really,
which is a tributary of the Amazon in Venezuela.
And he was studying the Yanomami people and um,
he wrote a thesis and calling them the fierce people saying that they,
they killed each other at such high rates.
And this justifies this hobbsy and view of the origins of human violence that
were really nasty and so we need these governments and religions to keep us in
check and you know,
it's very political,
right?
But he was just saying it's anthropology,
but it resonated with the culture of Vietnam was happening and there's all this
discussion of what,
why are we violent?
Is that our nature?
Or is it institutional,
you know,
the whole hippies versus the institution debate.
So anyway,
he wrote this book and it was a huge bestseller and he became super famous.
Turns out that when he went into this area,
he brought lots of machetes and these people didn't have lots of machetes.
They didn't have metal tools at all.
So he brings in the machetes and he starts giving the machetes to certain groups
in exchange for their cooperation.
And his research was on a genealogy,
so he needed to get the names of ancestors.
But it turns out that the Yanomami,
it's a great taboo to ever say the name of a dead person.
So what he would do is say,
okay,
I'll give you this machete if you tell me the names of the father and
grandfather have that guy from that other village,
so he would bribe them to get this information,
but that's a great taboo to say the names of that guy's father or grandfather,
right.
So then he would go to the other village and as a way to confirm whether the
information was correct,
he would say so and so over there said your father and grandfather were blah
blah blah and blah blah blah.
And if they got really pissed off,
he knew it was correct.
So that would confirm his information.
Then they would break,
they would have all these wars and they kill each other with these machetes.
And then he reported back saying,
Oh,
the Yanomami are very fierce destructive war like people and this is the origins
of humanity and Yada Yada.
Ya fucking bullshit,
man.
Complete Bullshit.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
So there is a book called darkness and El Dorado that came out a few years ago.
It was a big bestseller and exposed a lot of this stuff.
And it also went further and accused him of genocide,
him and this other guy,
neal,
for it accused them of using a vaccination program as a way to sort of test
immune responses.
And that appears to be for.
That appears to have been true.
Right.
But the other stuff with the machetes and sewing violence and all that,
and then reporting that their station from the other guy.
The other guy.
Yeah.
That's true.
About fucking group of victimized people trying to just get along and these
white people come along and fuck everything up.
Yeah.
And they even.
I write about the insects,
the situation in sex at dawn and they,
even the Yanomami have a special word called,
I think it's anthro,
which means like a crazy destructive white person.
And so he's not even allowed to go back to Venezuela.
He's barred from the country.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't know why I was talking about that.
I don't remember what 10.
Doesn't matter.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's.
Well,
it's just the distortion of the,
our,
our image of these people and how these crazy cultures can interrupt.
That might've been missionaries that cause these guys to blow all these kids and
by the time,
oh,
that's what I was rather.
I mean,
you see these interesting sexual practices all over the world and so they,
a lot of stuffs,
you know that.
When I was talking about that when last night at a cocktail party in Venice
actually I was talking with this gay guy and we were talking about how,
you know,
we think we know what it means to be gay,
but you look at a culture like that and you say,
well,
are they gay?
I know they consider it to be normal sexual development,
conventional,
you know,
that's what you do.
Or the Messiah,
the Messiah,
you know,
the herb's herdsmen new drink blood and milk in Kenya.
They have a similar sort of thing where the young,
younger boys go out on these long,
you know,
when they're out with the herds for weeks or months at a time.
They go out with the older boys and the older boys will have sex with them.
Not Anal sex,
but they'll um,
they'll put their penis between the thighs of the younger boy.
That was how the room is that?
Yeah,
there's a name for that.
I can't remember the word was specific word for it.
Either way.
It's still good.
Let them know.
Well,
that's the thing.
They would say it's not because then they get older.
They marry a woman.
They have kids.
That's just normal growing up.
Normal fuckery.
Yeah.
I'm not.
I think once you know what kind of a effect that has
on the young boys,
that's the thing.
If it's considered normal,
it doesn't knock it until you fight it.
Oh,
how dare you.
How dare you.
He was so proud of himself.
He was hanging out with Hinchcliffe too long.
The,
um,
the,
the idea though that it's not going to have an effect is only based on the fact
that they're going to do it to more young boys and they're not going to
complain.
And that's,
uh,
one of the weird things about sexual abuse is that it sort of re re manifests
itself in the victim and they start to be become a,
they become
the,
the accuser.
I mean,
they,
they also become the perpetrator.
They,
in fact that,
that a guy I was speaking to recently
who identifies as gay,
he said to me,
I don't think I was born gay.
I think I'm gay because I was sexually abused as a child by my stepfather from
the time I was three.
And we got into this whole discussion of how,
um,
it's,
there's the term erotic plasticity and how different it is for men and women in
men and males have other mammals.
There seems to be a developmental window where we imprint something and that
window closes and if you got an imprint that sticks with you for life,
which is why virtually all fetishist sermon,
right?
There are a lot of men who will say,
well,
I can't get off unless you know,
there's latex or she's wearing red high heeled shoes,
or she's got this or that.
Right?
You don't.
Women don't say that like women,
you know,
they're much more flexible and adapt to the situation.
So the idea is that if during that window you're imprinted with male,
male sex and pleasure involved with that,
then you could sort of like have that as a fetish even though you were born,
you know,
you're sort of genetic components or your brain development or whatever.
There are different theories is heterosexual.
So there are different.
According to this idea,
there are different ways to be gay.
You can be born gay or you could be,
you could be gay as a fetish in a way,
you know,
but anyway,
related to what you were saying about the trauma,
there's research showing that what really causes the trauma is the shame
generated by the culture that boys who are what we would call sexually abused or
girls who were sexually abused at a young age.
Uh,
if there's not pain involved,
right?
If it's inappropriate touching or whatever,
um,
the trauma comes about when they're told that was really bad and they're told
that that's a horrible thing that happened.
It doesn't necessarily come about from the experience itself.
And I don't mean this as to justify anything or
aren't there a variety of different types of experiences?
Are these consensual and just innocent or are these actual hold you down?
Rape.
That's what I'm saying.
It's physical
pains,
a whole different thing.
If it's just two little kids diddling each other,
you know,
some mothers would say that's abuse.
That's a horrible,
oh my God,
what happened?
The best thing to do is just say,
hey,
nothing happened.
You know,
it's no big deal.
Right?
Um,
and there are psychological studies showing that the lasting effects are
negligible and less.
It's framed as,
oh my God,
what happened?
That completely makes sense.
As does the framing thing,
the framing thing completely makes sense as well,
that there's something happens in their life and they just get imprinted and
that's been otherwise,
why would so many abuse victims become abusers themselves?
You would think that like you,
the last thing you would do is repeat that,
right?
Oh my God,
that's the thing that fucked you up and ruined you.
You would say like,
man,
I would never want to do this to another person and that would be how would we
would evolve.
So it seems like there's like a hitch in the developmental process that allows
weird things just to be accepted and become the standard,
right?
They become eroticized and associated with pleasure and so you try to relive
them later.
There's a great experiment with,
um,
it happened in Scotland I think where they took a one year,
they had like a herd of goats and a herd of sheep and so they took all the
babies,
all the baby goats and put them with the sheep and they took all the baby sheep
and put them with the goats.
So they were raised thinking they were the other species,
right?
So all the goats grew up around the sheep thinking I'm just a weird looking
cheap.
Right.
And the vice versa.
So the way till they got sexually mature and started having sex and then they
switched them back.
And what happened was that the males refused to have sex with their own species
because they had learned that none of the male goats and learn like I fuck
sheep.
No,
I fucked goats.
The females were like,
yeah,
whatever.
You know,
they just sort of like went with it.
But the males refused.
They were stuck with it because they were imprinted.
And that was it.
That is fascinating.
Yeah.
What the fuck,
evolutionary purposes that play.
Who knows?
That's a good question.
I don't know,
but it's,
it's a common mistake I would say in,
and I'm not saying just among people reading books for the first time among
experts,
there's a mistake of thinking that everything has an evolutionary function.
I say sometimes it could just be the,
the tide went that way and that's what happened.
And there's a,
there's something Stephen Jay Gould,
the great evolutionary theorist called spandrels,
which are things that look like they have a function,
but they're actually sort of a side effect of something else.
You know,
like the chin,
you know,
why did the Chin evolved the way it did?
Well,
we have a word for this thing we call the chin,
but it's not actually a thing.
It's where the two jawbones fuse,
so it's,
it does,
you know,
it exists as linguistic concept,
but not necessarily as a biological concept.
So they're,
they're weird,
you know,
they're murky waters.
You can get lost and when you're looking at evolutionary stuff,
and he always advised people.
You always say,
what's the evolutionary function of that?
Be Clear on what that is and that it actually would necessarily have an
evolutionary function.
You know,
I've always been fascinated by why at the same time all over the world,
people who are human beings or you can breed with each other but have such
incredibly varied ways of behaving and that this has always been this way.
I'm really into this.
I'm Dan Carlin,
a podcast recently.
He's got this podcast called hardcore history and he does this really detailed
history of the Mongols over like five,
five episodes and it's amazing.
It's amazing.
It's just fucking craziness.
The way these people just took over Europe and just conquered and just the
madness and the how they were so different from anyone that existed at that time
and that they were so extreme and intense,
but at the same time that they lived somewhere in the Amazon,
there are a bunch of people do an Iowaska eating fish and you know,
polyamorous people and it's amazing that this all took place all along.
And during the same time.
Do you ever read the travels of Marco Polo?
No.
You know the story.
He's like 14 hundreds or something like that at 13 hundreds.
And he went to.
He was with the Mongols and he walked all across Asia on the spice route with
his uncles.
And uh,
yeah,
he was with a,
I don't know if it was gang con or Kubelet icon or which,
which of the Mongo kings it was.
And along the way talking about interesting people,
he stayed with the most.
Well,
people of southwestern China who still exists and uh,
apparently still have this very interesting marital,
well,
not even marital sexual behavior where both men and women are completely
autonomous.
Sexual beings,
you have sex with whomever you want.
There's no slut shaming,
there's no shame involved with multiple partners.
Whatever you do,
what you want.
When a girl becomes sexually mature,
she gets her own room called a flower room that has a door that opens into the
central courtyard of her mother's house where she lives and also has a door that
opens into the street.
And so that girl from,
you know,
13,
14,
whatever,
sexual maturity,
she can let anyone.
She wants to come in and spend the night in her room with her.
The only rule is he can't be there for breakfast,
right?
So no,
no,
nobody's invited for breakfast,
get get out by sunrise,
but she can sleep with whoever she wants.
Then what happens when she gets pregnant is that the child is cared for by
her brothers and her sisters.
So as a man,
your paternal responsibility is to your sister's kids,
not to your biological child.
In fact,
biological fatherhood is,
is,
is a nonissue in this society is amazing.
Yeah.
Really interesting society.
It's,
it's the law in,
in um,
Marco Polo stayed with them and he wrote about them and he thought typical
Italian,
right?
He thought that he was screwing these women behind the men's backs and,
you know,
play Marco polos getting he was getting.
So he just thought he was slick.
He thought he was a cool guy,
but it turns out the women were just like,
Yo,
that's funny.
It is amazing.
When you think about the variables,
it's amazing when you think about the variety of different cultures that evolve
simultaneously over the world and how is it their environment that causes that?
Or is it,
this is a missionaries move in and give them machetes and talk about their
ancestors.
I mean the various,
the various things that happen or.
So.
Um,
and I know I confuse those two stores.
The missionary and the researcher.
No,
it's all you mean.
Yeah.
And smallpox comes in and then you get the ice ages and you know,
but I,
I,
I tend to be a materialist.
There's a book called cultural materialism by Marvin Harris,
which is a great book.
And he wrote a more popular book called Cannibals and Kings,
which covers some of the same stuff.
And He,
like,
he looked at things like why are some societies cannibals and others aren't,
right.
So you've got the,
you know,
the clash of European societies and the Aztecs and the mind and all that.
And so,
you know,
you can't say the Europeans weren't blood thirsty,
crazy killers.
They just didn't eat what they killed the people they killed.
Whereas the Aztecs were killing the people that are eating the people they
killed.
Why is that?
Or why on some South Pacific islands where the people cannibalistic and others,
they weren't right.
So what he did was he did a,
a materialistic analysis.
And what he found was that without exception in the societies that were
cannibalistic,
there was no other source of protein that didn't compete with humans for the
same food.
So like they didn't have pigs,
right?
Pigs will eat stuff.
Humans,
canny,
right?
So you can raise pigs without feeding them your own food.
But dogs,
you feed them stuff you would eat because dogs eat meat.
Right?
So in Mexico there was nothing that they could raise,
no,
no animal that could be domesticated that they could raise for meat.
And so that's why they eat the dead people because they were protein starved.
Wow.
And then you apply that same thing to the different islands in the South Pacific
and he found the same.
And American Indians,
native Americans in the harshest climates were the ones that we're tending
towards cannibalism like towards the Great Lakes,
like the,
uh,
the native American people from the Great Lakes area.
Those are the ones that,
uh,
there's uh,
stories of
cannibalizing people.
Yeah.
And you also have.
Yeah,
in Midwinter Yeah,
sure.
But also in,
in that kind of thing,
you want to look at ritualistic cannibalism versus like,
okay,
dinner time,
you know?
Yeah.
Because they,
they had some interesting torture ceremonies as well in those Canadian Great
Lakes Iroquois,
kind of that.
It was an honor to be tortured to death.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
Steven Rinella guy that I was telling you about,
his book mediator,
I,
he told me some crazy stories about the people that lived off the Missouri,
the Missouri River,
like in Montana and trappers and all these different people that have these
conflicts with the Indians and other would kill them.
And there was a lot of cannibalism going on,
a lot more than I would've ever imagined.
It's because that's not really something that gets brought up in high school
history or you know,
they don't,
they don't really tell you,
oh by the way,
occasionally used to eat people as did the settlers and our,
you know,
the Donner Party,
North America itself is one of the most spectacular examples of how quickly
things can change.
You're right,
if you stop and think about North America just a thousand years ago,
just $1,000 anywhere in Europe.
1,000.
It's like there's still people,
man,
they're still the nuttiness.
There's still.
I've hung out in bars that were more than a thousand years old,
I'm sure.
What is the oldest bar in,
um,
in London as they're like a bar.
That's when like the fucking,
I dunno,
Barcelona,
I could take you to them.
Uh,
how old are below them?
Well,
the oldest continually open bar is from the 1700 I made.
I'll bother and I've been there many times.
But the place I'm thinking of when,
when I've said the thousand years old,
it's a bar down in the Gulf decaux section of Barcelona where one wall of the
bar is a Roman wall from the original Roman building that was there.
So you're like leaning up against the Romans while drinking your beer.
It's really cool.
Holy Shit.
Not America.
And that's 2000 years old a thousand years ago.
No Manhattan,
no Los Angeles,
no Chicago,
no Atlanta.
Just stop and think of that alone.
Just what radical changes to the landscape we've seen over the past few hundred
years.
We get a thousand thousand years ago.
You wind up in New York on a boat and what are you,
what are you looking at?
Looking at some fucking wooden shacks.
The huddled up together eating beaver pelts.
Fuck you.
Looking at
this thing has changed so fast.
I,
I met a guy at a wedding a few years ago who was like,
one of the world's leading experts on seashells.
Sounds Kinda boring,
right?
But we ended up talking about wampum and he told me something I'd never read
anywhere,
which,
you know,
wampum writers made from seashells.
This was like the,
the name,
but I don't know what it was that native Americans
used in the northeast.
Right when,
when the Dutch first arrived in the very early days of New York is what reminded
me of it.
It was made from a particular type of seashell that only grew in a certain area.
So like all currencies,
it had a very restricted source,
you know,
like gold or whatever,
beaver pelts or whatever it was.
It's,
by the way,
you know,
that's why 20 bucks,
that's deer skins.
That deer screens are used as currency and the colonial period.
Yeah,
that's why we say 20 bucks.
Yeah.
But anyway,
so the Wampum,
they'd make these belts of wampum that you could use to buy and sell things.
Right?
So the Dutch clever bastards that they are figured out how they were making this
wampum and what sort of seashells it was and they,
they learn to cultivate that particular molecule.
They were basically printing,
you know,
counterfeit wampum.
Wow.
So they didn't even just rip off the Indians when they bought Manhattan.
They bought it with fake money.
Holy Shit.
Fake Indian money.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
They bought it with seashells.
And imagine how much your condo goes for now and just think that the whole thing
went for seashells.
That's a change in the real estate market right there.
You know what I love?
I lived in Manhattan for a few years and last year I was there.
I worked in a construction site and since we're just talking randomly
interesting things here,
the guy,
one of the laborers on the construction site explain to me why the buildings are
really high in midtown and then they go down and then they go back up and
they're high again down in Wall Street and the financial district.
If you look at Manhattan from New Jersey,
you're from queens or Brooklyn or whatever the.
I always thought that was just like what you're saying is like there are all
these strange things that come together,
whether it's finance or you know,
whatever happens,
stand.
Somebody wanted to it here.
There it turns out,
no,
there's a logic to this and the logic is that the,
the,
the rock that grant,
the geological rock comes up near the surface at midtown and then it goes way
down again and that Anders Soho in the village and all that,
and then it comes back up close to the surface at Wall Street.
So to build a really tall building,
you have to drill,
anchor it into the rock.
So you can't do that where there's a lot of dirt you'd have to like dig down so
far to get to excavate the whole.
So you can only build a 50 story building where the bedrock is close to the
surface and you can anchor it into there.
Right?
So it's stable.
Totally makes sense.
So what you're seeing when you look at that skyline is like an echo of the
geology of the island.
Wow.
Interesting.
That is a,
that is absolutely fascinating.
Um,
brings me up to this quote I was going to bring up earlier when you talked about
Marshall Mcluhan.
A lot of folks don't know Marshall Mcluhan was,
but he said a lot of amazing things and one of the things he said,
I think it was either the fifties,
I think he said in the fifties,
he said that man becomes the sex organs of the machine world.
That's beautiful.
The craziest statement ever.
Have you stop and think about how premature it was and our,
our,
how precocious it was to say that in whatever he said that in 1950 or 1960 and
look at what's going on now with our symbiotic connection to technology.
The true machine that's taking over,
that's,
I'm writing that down because I'm going to use that thing.
I thought about that so many times without even having read his quote,
but I wasn't able to put it so eloquently in my head because that if that the
faith look like a life form.
I mean I have skeletons in my garage.
It's an old Mac,
old shitty fucking like Tan thing with the stupid rainbow apple on it.
I have one of those things.
It's like really old.
It's hilarious.
I look at it,
I'm like,
this is like a dinosaur,
so might as well be like a dead dinosaur,
dead useless thing and now you know,
we don't have dinosaurs anymore.
Now we got chickens,
you know,
now whatever.
I mean,
it really does seem like.
Yeah,
I wrote an article about the future of sex for this European.
They called the European magazine.
It's,
I guess it's a German magazine,
but they publish in English as well.
He asked me to write this thing a few months ago and I could have used that
McLuhan quote that was really good.
But I said like basically the way I see the future of sex is peeling off in two
different possible directions depending upon whether there's world collapse or
not.
And uh,
if there's not,
I see us as many people do merging with machines,
what do they call it?
The singularity,
but also in terms of sexuality that you know,
now we've got flashlights,
but in a few years we're going to have holographic images.
We're going to have like the technology is always driven by this sexual hunger.
There's a book called the erotic engine where this guy argues that every
communication advance was driven by money coming from orotic energy,
you know,
vhs tapes and then dvds and the Internet,
like all the first monies coming in for porn,
you know,
even photography
first,
a adapters,
first time adapters like html five and all that.
As soon as soon as people realized that the iphone wasn't going to go with flash
and that a html five seemed like the future when it comes to a animated things
online,
porn went right to it.
Sure.
You know,
whereas a lot of websites,
you still,
you go to it on an iphone and it'll show you the adobe thing.
Not supported and not porn.
They figured out right away I had him on the ball.
Yeah.
They gotta make it so you could watch people fuck on your phone.
Isn't it amazing though that that is a sort of,
again,
in the closet,
it's sort of a background sort of reality,
like all the banks in Miami being funded by cocaine.
Everybody knows it,
but nobody talks about it.
Right.
You know,
why is there so many banks,
Miami?
Because that's where the
fucking cocaine came from.
Why?
Why is,
why is technology moving towards html five?
Why is what,
what is online streaming technology?
Where's its roots?
Its roots are in people watching people.
Fuck.
That's where they got it down.
That's where they get really good at it and that's where the money is.
And then that might.
I mean,
what percentage of that was responsible for the development of the CD Rom?
What percentage of the.
You know,
how much I would like to know about the erotic engine that he talks about all
that.
Yeah,
because before the Internet came along,
I mean how many people bought movies as supposed to?
How many people bought dirty movies?
What was the share of the market?
Fucking chunk,
right.
Well,
Miss Cinemas,
the porn.
That was another thing from your book that I found completely fascinating.
I didn't think about was how we have this idea of corporate America not being
not profit profiting in porn,
but how in fact like chains of hotels are like the biggest porn providers in the
world.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're making huge proportion of their profits from those on demand movies.
Last week when I was in San Diego,
I literally went through the whole entire list of porn because they were so
funny.
Titles.
It was probably 300 titles that they just had their
and they're selling for like what,
20 bucks or $10,
whatever it is.
I mean that's pure profit at a certain point,
you know,
and once they pay the licensing fee off or whatever it is,
so them.
And you know what it was the other example you had of people that were profiting
off point that you would not expect.
Yeah,
I don't remember.
I remember the,
the corporate thing you're talking about and I think the corporation in question
might've been coca cola or somebody owned by Mormons or something.
It was some like really conservative public image,
but they were the biggest supplier to the hotel chains.
Yeah.
And they were definitely going to be hilarious.
Chick fil a is only into chickens and Dixon Asad said the other day I
interviewed Nina Hartley from podcast.
She's really interested in how to run away from her.
She was on Kevin Prayers podcast and as soon as she's talking about how she only
has sex with gloves on,
I was like,
bitch,
you lost me.
I lost me bitch.
I got to go.
She only had sex with Linda fisting and finger souls and plus these and she
doesn't want fingernails.
And I mean it makes sense,
but it's because she's a goddamn professional.
I mean she's got the pro clinic goal.
Snap a rubber glove approach to sex.
She's also a nurse.
She has her own flashlight,
right?
She's got her own and resembles a metal hitting a large mammal.
What you would get.
Nice Lady.
She's not freak.
She's.
Yeah,
she is smart.
She's an old hippie freak.
That's what she is,
you know?
Yeah.
But I got walk.
That's where I got to walk away.
We start talking about
I only have sex with gloves on.
Okay.
Last me gold bond on it.
And then I rub it,
she's not that old dude.
You made her like,
she's something past a MILF though,
right?
It's like we talked to.
She's a new categories.
Fifty three,
54,
somewhere in there.
Still fucking throwing down.
Broken down.
She's an educator.
She's good.
You're talking about gloves mean we had a friend of mine told me this story.
He,
he was with a woman who is polyamorous.
Right?
And so he,
he,
you know,
whatever they're going out to dinner and he gets a text from her a few hours
before dinner saying,
look,
I'm,
I just want to be upfront about this as polyamorous people off in art.
My agreement with my partner is,
um,
what,
what was the detail or the,
the agreement is no,
no,
uh,
intercourse,
so we can do whatever else but no intercourse.
Right?
So He's thinking,
well,
Geez,
I thought it was just dinner.
Right?
So I guess,
right.
That's pretty good news.
I mean,
it seems like everything else is on the table.
So then they end up back in her place and she says,
oh,
sorry,
the,
you know,
we,
the rule changed a little bit.
Now it's like,
I know genital contact.
So they're making out.
And she says,
okay,
sorry,
you know,
my boyfriend says no genital contact,
right?
So he says,
okay,
that's fine.
So then she says,
wait a minute,
they're getting all hot and heavy.
She says,
wait a minute,
she goes to the other room,
she comes back and she's got these black latex gloves on and she starts giving
him a hand job because like,
apparently with the gloves there's no contact and then she gives him a Dildo.
So there's like,
all this crazy stuff is going on.
And he told me this story.
He's like,
this was so far beyond what I would have anticipated.
Exactly.
And it got really freaky because of these rules.
Of course,
it made me think about drugs,
you know,
like,
hey,
if coca leaf is illegal,
well then they're going to make cocaine.
You know,
if grasp,
if you can't just grow grass in your backyard,
then you're going to get hydroponic,
you know,
super grass.
It's like you make these rules,
you know,
like hard liquor,
right?
Prohibition is what started gin and all this kind of stuff,
So you make rules to try to contain a natural human appetite and what happens is
it gets explosive,
right?
Just like a bomb.
The bomb needs the containment to be explosive,
otherwise it's just nothing.
It gets a natural human inclination that I could see loud and clearly with my
kids.
When you try to keep kids from doing things,
they automatically like,
why the fuck should I listen to you?
I want,
that's what I want to do.
They get angry.
It's like it's a natural human response because all of our entire history of
humanity has been people trying to dominate people,
people trying to control people.
So our natural thing is to resist.
It's why the biggest slut always have like super religious parents.
There you go.
Jesus Christ.
Folks.
Is it that easy?
Does Dr Christopher Ryan have to explain it that easy?
Yes.
Nina Hartley's.
Parents interestingly,
were communists who were blacklisted in Berkeley.
Really?
Interesting.
Yeah,
she's an old hippy.
She's a,
she's a,
she's an odd case.
Yeah,
she like,
she's one of the rare ones where you,
you always connect human,
like girls who were into porn or getting into that,
you always connected with some sort of an abuse.
Yeah.
You know,
some human aberration,
but now with her she seems like just a crazy old hippie freak doesn't seem
dirty.
It's fun.
Like,
yeah,
it's weird.
Yeah,
no,
she's,
she's an interesting person.
I enjoy.
What is the,
what is the weirdest thing you've gotten out of this study of human sexuality
because it's,
your book is incredibly enlightening and I think Dunkin's uh,
his,
uh,
definition of you as a shame exercise is really a perfect one because it puts so
many things into perspective and it makes,
it makes so many weird patterns of behavior that we follow.
It's sort of enlightens you on the origins of them,
but what is like one of the weirdest things that you've found in this pursuit?
Well yeah,
there are so many,
you know,
obviously these things pop up in every conversation,
but I think one of the most,
uh,
memorable and,
and moving in a way was when I went looking for the first documented case of a
key parties and,
you know,
partner swapping and that sort of thing in,
in modern America,
not these sex in the 19th century,
20th century stuff.
I thought it would be,
um,
you know,
some commune in Berkeley with a bunch of hippies and Hendrix posters and,
whatever waterbeds and,
you know,
that Kinda thing.
And uh,
but it wasn't,
it was World War Two fighter pilots in the Pacific who had the highest fatality
rate of any branch of the military in World War II.
Twenty five percent of them died in action when they were back on base,
I guess in Hawaii or the west coast.
They had key parties where they and their partners would come to these parties,
put the keys in,
you know,
like in the ice storm.
I don't know if you saw that movie,
great movie,
um,
and randomly sleep with each other's wives or girlfriends.
Right?
And um,
you know,
these are all like super,
genetically.
Yeah,
good looking dudes.
All Alpha males obviously and the women they were with were hot.
So I don't think anyone was worried about,
you know,
pulling the short straw to the,
the short key.
Um,
but,
you know,
I,
I thought,
well,
okay sure,
these guys are facing death.
They want to get it while they can.
Right.
But then in the interviews I read with the survivors,
what they said was,
yeah,
okay,
we were young,
we were strong,
we were,
have,
you know,
we were getting laid but we could have gotten laid anywhere.
You know,
we could have gone to a bar and gotten lay.
We did because
we wanted those other guys.
We wanted our buddies to love our women so that if I die,
I know these guys will take care of her because they love her because they've
been with her.
They know her.
Right?
It's like it,
it moved me so much to read that because a lot of the accounts from the Amazon
are the same.
These guys are facing a difficult life.
You can go hunting one day and you get your,
the Hunty,
you know,
things can go wrong really fast,
so you want people to love each other,
not exclusively because then they take care of each other,
they take care of each other's kids,
they share their food,
they,
you know,
they look out for each other.
And that's really the essence of humanity.
Have you explored the idea that the opposite trend that we are finding ourselves
in now where people are just gravitating towards monogamy at least culturally,
at least on paper,
that this,
uh,
this move towards that ideal is because we're safer is because we're more likely
to be protected.
We don't need these.
We in sort of a natural inclination to move towards a deeper bond with one
individual person.
I don't know that I'd call it a natural inclination,
but you know,
I,
I tend to see it more as a byproduct of institutional and economic forces.
I see that as also being natural.
And I know it sounds very contradictory when I look at Wolf behavior.
Yeah,
I,
I don't take our crazy fucked up weird behavior and not think that it's natural.
Even though there's consciousness involve and choices involved,
there's something about the pattern of human behavior.
When I look at it as a whole,
where I see it's kind of arrogant to assume that this isn't natural.
It seems that almost everything is natural.
That's the thing.
It depends how you define.
I mean you could,
if you take a real
global perspective,
you could say as I tend to think of it that we are not where the ants and the
ant hill and the ant hill is what's evolving and that's the sort of the,
the,
the location of the selection.
In other words,
as individuals,
we think we're what's evolving,
but I think what's evolving is society's corporations,
these institutions that,
that include us and they don't give a shit if we're happy or not.
This,
this larger being that we're in or a
part of as we fuel them with electricity,
with commerce,
with whatever.
They literally act like a life form.
This is the same way as technology.
Like Marshall Mcluhan said,
we are the sexual organs.
Those machines,
well,
as we fuel the,
the,
the desire for new laptops,
we keep that alive.
Right.
And,
and you know,
uh,
when Mitt Romney said corporations are people in my friend,
I don't think he was thinking in these terms,
but they're not people,
but they're living beings,
they have a stake and staying alive.
They have a vested interest and if step on us to do it,
they'll do it,
you know,
fucking crazy is that.
And they can get to do it for them.
Frankenstein,
you know,
that was the whole Frankenstein myth and it's happier,
don't fear it.
Don't you know how in 2001 it's here,
it's,
it's been happening for quite awhile.
Monsanto doesn't give a shit if they produce food that kills us.
No,
as long as they've cornered the market,
well they also produce DDT and Agent Orange.
Sure.
So itself,
they've been making fucked up choices for a long time.
You know what I told that story about the pilots in San Diego.
I was given a talk down there and this guy came up to me after and he said,
I'm a,
I'm A.
I was a fighter pilot in Vietnam.
Same thing.
Different war,
same thing.
Wow.
So it's a natural behavior pattern.
Apparently it's a culture among fighter pilots that a,
they.
Well that they're facing death.
Right.
And,
and I found it.
I'd done a lot of research and hospitals and I found a very amplified sexuality
in hospitals center because they're facing as well.
Cops.
Yeah,
sure.
Anybody who's on the edge and Hulk Hogan,
Hulk Hogan Swim.
That MMA fighter.
No,
he's not.
He's just interviewed at the airport and just said something silly.
Everybody blew that out of proportion.
Yeah.
Hulk Hogan,
they used to.
He was a web swapper.
The AG guys,
much of the.
Was it the New York jets and the giants had Ryan.
There was this.
Did you hear about this?
No,
this controversy because there were,
there were pictures on the Internet of him,
his wife and another dude,
and the wife was like either naked or in lingerie and the other dude was sucking
her toes.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's where I checked out
the glove.
Weird about that,
man.
We're real weird about that.
It's interesting.
It's a,
it's,
it's fascinating to just see the trends and how they've,
how they've changed with the environment.
Yeah,
and how different they are as you were saying in cultures like there was a at
the same time that thing was happening in the states and it was a huge to do.
There was a soccer coach in England who got nabbed coming out of a massage
parlor with happy endings and all that and the press was there and snapping all
these pictures and they said,
do you know their tie?
How hookers in there?
He said,
of course I know die yolkers in this,
why?
I go there.
And it was like,
what,
how dare you not be ashamed,
you know?
And then they went and interviewed his wife and his wife said,
Oh God,
if I could get him to go to Thai hookers twice a week,
I'd pay for it.
It relaxes him.
He's better at his job.
You know,
how is this any of your business?
Just completely trumped the,
the,
you know,
the assumption that she'd be ashamed and run away from it.
Like,
Hey,
this is none of your damn business.
Sounds like you've got a good wife.
Nailed it.
Imagine if the Clintons had done that.
Maybe they did in,
you
know,
maybe you think they did.
Maybe Hillary was just mad that he wasn't bringing checks home.
I mean,
who knows,
who fucking cares either those businesses.
Oh,
it's just so weird how the desire for sex and our appetite for sex is not
represented in any way.
I mean it's represented a bit in the media and film and advertising and stuff
like that,
but it's not.
Honestly,
it's not honestly engaged.
It's not honestly described.
It's funny though because like I saw this Carter or in a cartoon,
a commercial a couple of weeks ago for some plunger or some plumbing thing to
clear your drains and it,
the,
the idea was,
and it was,
you know,
the whatever the major brand plumbing thing is and this stuff has the chemical
nastiness,
but it also has like a plastic thing you can stick down to pull the hair thing.
And so it was like double action.
Right?
And so the ad was,
this woman answers the door and it's this really good looking dude,
and the dude's like,
yeah,
I'm here to snake your drain baby.
And she says,
oh.
And she's like,
all flustered in,
Oh yes,
come with me.
And then someone else knocks and she opened it.
It's another dude.
And he's like,
yeah,
I'm here to help.
Oh,
oh,
two of you.
Oh,
what?
What country?
That's here in the states.
And I,
I linked to it.
I,
I tweeted,
I said,
has this actually been on TV?
Because someone sent me the link on Youtube.
I said,
has anyone seen this on TV?
And a bunch of people.
Rebecca.
Oh yeah.
I've seen it on TV.
It's on
like,
wow.
Wow.
What's up with that?
Well,
congratulations,
whoever company put that out.
Graduations for sneaking that through.
Can we?
Can we end on that?
Can we pull that out?
It's quite good.
It's,
it's,
I think it's plunger,
dual action plunger or whatever that somebody can find that to tool action
plunger.
That's hilarious.
The woman's like in the grocery store and she sees these two guys and has this
whole fantasy.
What's going on with that TV show that?
Well,
it's great,
man.
Last time I was here I guess we talked probably off the air,
but.
But I'm like a whole shitload of production companies want to do it.
Everybody thinks it's going to go.
Is this it?
Yeah.
Impact.
Total impacts are.
So here's snake.
He's hot.
He's hot too.
I'm here to flush your pipe.
Wow.
She's letting her hair down and everything while he's going to go upstairs and
there's just nothing but shit.
She takes these massive logging or poop.
He's fucking wood chips.
It's just not blood.
The very.
And She just woke up.
That's her.
That's her fantasy.
Yeah.
The under sex housewife shits reality
and the gay guy holding the fruit.
The Gay guy working with the melons.
The two of them are just gonna.
Use her as an excuse to get together.
That's how they're doing.
That's what double penetration is when two guys,
when they're both in the vagina at the same time,
they're just using the woman as a container.
So they could rub dicks.
Com.
Scrotum,
buddies.
Yeah,
that's what they're doing.
Listen,
a fascinating.
Again,
three hours just flew right by.
Matt.
We could do this every time.
We still talked about like one paragraph and your book will come.
We'll cover it.
One page,
but it's a brilliant book.
And folks,
if you haven't read it,
it's called sex at dawn.
You can get it on Amazon,
which is a sponsor of the show.
Um,
it's available as an audio book.
It's also available of course in,
in book form and it's fucking great.
And you were working on another book too.
Civilized today.
Is that,
is that coming out soon?
It's due October first.
Should come out next spring unless I don't get to it.
All right.
I'm going to start real soon.
Sex at dawn.
It's available now.
And your podcast,
how do people get it?
Tangentially speaking.
You can get it@aferalaudio.com or you can get it on itunes.
It's on itunes.
Beautiful.
And it's Chris Ryan,
phd on twitter and thanks brother.
Really appreciate it.
Always good times.
All right.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
Thanks.
Everybody.
Came out to Nashville this weekend.
We had a great fucking time.
Nashville was awesome.
I was exactly what I needed.
Wanted to go to a small club in a workout,
some new material.
And Man,
there's nothing like working at a comedy club.
I've been doing a lot of theaters lately.
I forgot how much fun it is to do a weekend,
like a 300 seater.
Nashville is awesome.
What a fucking great town.
Thank you everybody who came out because uh,
I had the time of my life.
It was,
it was beautiful and Tommy bonds was with me as well.
Thompson girl.
We had a great time.
It was seriously some of the best sets I've ever had in my life.
People were amazing.
Thanks to squarespace for sponsoring this episode of the podcast.
If you go to squarespace.com forward slash joe,
or you could sign up.
You don't even have to use your credit card,
but if you decided to sign up,
use the code named Joe and the number three and you will save yourself some
Moolah.
You sexy bitches and you're like,
no way Joe.
And I'm like,
yeah,
way save some money and it's an awesome fucking website.
We're also brought to you by on it.com.
That's o n n I t use the codename Rogan and you could save yourself 10 percent
of any and all supplements.
Go to a Rogan dot tin top con.
That is our last and final sponsor that's painting is the cell phone company
that doesn't have contracts and rolls over your minutes and they're just
basically bad ass Rogan.ting.com will save you 25 bucks off either service or a
phone.
Uh,
we will be back tomorrow with the Great Bill Burger,
one of my favorite human beings.
Some of the funniest comics working today.
And uh,
so we'll see you then.
You fucks,
we love the shit out of you and we'll see you soon.
Big Kiss.
Yeah.